business
ES
call the March 3rd meeting of the
resource of recreation and
development committee uh call up to call
the meeting to order
hearing it will you have both earrings
we will have a
work session and we will be doing
Executives Executives sessions
throughout the day first let me allow me
to read the Chairman's script
play this topic
as chair of house resources Recreation
and development committee I find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the
covid-19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rules 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12. pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronic lifters
this is a public hearing with the
potential for executive sessions to
occur throughout
please note that there is no physical
location from members of the public to
observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate
in this meeting by the zoom platform or
by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting
the notice for this meeting notice
complies with house rules and RSA 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
OMG I want to introduce the staff
that are on this meeting assisting us
Brad Greenland committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taking the ring this meeting shall be
done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call of attendance when each member
states their presence please also State
whether they are there is anyone in the
room with you during the meeting which
is required under the right to know one
and that is that I will ask
reading this It'll ask the clerk to
please please call the roll thank you Mr
chair uh representative gunski
on his way
uh representative Gould can you call her
last she she's just signing okay
um representative Morgan
and I'm home alone
uh representative harb
I'm present and I'm in my office
currently alone
representative Brighton or present
representative Dodge
present and alone
the clerk is here
representative Healy here representative
Mayville
present and alone good morning
representative post
she just signed on so she should be good
yes present and in a loft area so people
may be going through throughout the day
representative Smith
present and here at home alone
representative Spang
president and here alone
representative Grassi
president and I'm here alone
representative gottling
[Applause]
here alone
representative Cohen
here and I'm alone
representative Connors
here I'm in my office and I'm alone
representative Vale
here in my office Home Alone
representative Kelly
here and alone
representative Moran
okay representative Gould Linda Gould
representative gold is here in a big
room and alone
chairman renzullo I am here in the
committee room
and
yeah
is not here uh when he comes in we will
login
insurance
oh I don't have her name and the uh yeah
uh and there's
uh represent representative Smith uh
person who is uh filling in for you I
didn't get the
oh it's filling in that's it
representative dutsie
can you spell that please D is in David
u-t-z-y
Sherry first name
s h e e r r y okay thank you and
okay representative dutzie
that's uh in my home office alone okay
and representative gunski
uh
uh it's a little bit about what how
we're going to proceed this morning uh
we're at nine o'clock which is
uh we're gonna have we are having a
continuation
uh continue uh continuation of a hearing
for House Bill
184 and that's to get gather additional
information that the committee felt
needed uh in order to make decisions on
on the bill uh then we've uh right at 9
30 we will go into a a work session
uh which
the the work session will be again be on
House Bill 184. the difference between a
Committee hearing and a work session
is that the work session is the public
May
view it but it is not
but cannot participate and give
testimony unless
uh there is unless it is to answer a
question that the
that the committee feels that they need
and that question has to come through
the chair so uh yes yes
so that that is really the only
difference that you will see is just see
the committee will just be working we'll
add we'll be discussing the bill with uh
uh but without
public input unless requested
um and then
uh we that F at the end of that
We Will We Will exec
we'll start executing we'll exec 184 and
then uh we'll be executing uh bill from
the bills that are still that are that
that have that are still
and we'll continue doing that until 11
o'clock then we will have a full that we
will
uh have full committee will go and have
hearings on 397 and noon we will break
for lunch and at one o'clock we will do
4 46 and then we will go back into
executive session to finish up all the
bills
[Music]
continuation the hearing and house bill
184.
representative Murray
are you there
is very
is there hair raising here
okay
representative Murray are you there
that's their hand is not his name she's
transferring okay
representative Murray
good morning can you hear me now yes yes
we can yeah and can you see me as well I
was never sure
uh
uh yeah because all I see is a whole yes
we can
all right um I guess I have information
to share with you you've received the
packet I believe and you received a
couple naps so I will reference one map
but I just want to take about five
minutes to go over
some of the specific things that were
asked before
um you have in your pack it reports
which describe Damage Done by personal
watercraft in an environmentally
sensitive area the number of these
reports are from personal watercraft
companies who promote responsible usages
they all support showing respect for
environmentally sensitive areas and the
best way to support
um these are the usage is to clearly
Mark areas where personal watercraft are
not appropriate I'm sure you've gone
through the information yourself but
there are a few highlights that I'd like
to bring forth from these reports from
thrillcraft there's a report on the
environmental consequences of motorized
Recreation the Highlight that wake waves
from pwcs can create serious shoreline
erosion creating turbidity and
sedimentation problems in shallow and
productive Waters in addition personal
watercraft have more serious negative
impacts on birds including Interruption
of normal feeding activity repeated
displacement from nesting areas then
conventional motor boats cars
all-terrain vehicles and even
pedestrians from the environmental guide
for watercraft operators put out by the
personal watercraft industry Association
in Shallow Waters boots May stir off the
bottom and suspend sediments which limit
light penetration and deplete oxygen
this can affect fish and bird feeding
vegetation such as seagrasses are
delicate Nursery grounds where many of
the fish in our Waters originate when
possible operate a fair distance from
the shore because Wildlife tends to
inhabit this vegetation along the edge
of the shore
the best way to avoid disturbing the
local ecosystem is to stay in the marks
channels and the deeper areas of a lake
or river when possible
many migratory birds are easily stressed
and are especially vulnerable during
their migration periods birds will
typically fly away from disturbing
noises and from unnecessary expenditure
of energy can cause harm to a feeding or
a resting bird excessive boat wakes May
contribute to shoreline erosion
especially in narrow streams and inlets
this organization recognizing the damage
that can be done cautions PWC users to
avoid such areas it can be very
difficult to not know which areas are
sensitive and which are not to have
clear signage about areas of particular
sensitivity can help direct PWC users
away from these areas
from the University of Vermont a study
concludes that when the unburned fuel is
released into the water tiny organisms
absorb the chemicals and become
extremely sensitive to light and
occurrence called phototoxicity
the daylight Sun then kills the organism
which collapses causes a collapse of the
food chain as food sources slowly become
eliminated
finally from environmental guide for
watercraft operators there's a list of
all the various types of damage
including turbidity vegetation noise
erosion and sea grasses again the guide
recommends staying away from such areas
clearly demarcating the areas provides
guidance to PWC users who typically do
not want to damage the environment
there was a concern that a restriction
would adversely affect particular
businesses it is in my view rather
absurd to think that someone is going to
be deterred from purchasing a jet ski
because they cannot use it in a few
hundred square yards of wetlands out of
the miles and miles of navigable
waterways surrounding us
I also want to mention that this is a
constituent-driven bill by the residents
who live in Rye and in Newcastle the
people who are directly affected by the
impact of the jet skis and see by and
large on a daily basis the fragility and
the sensitivity of the area in which
they live
operators are not always aware of their
surroundings and having having these
sensitive areas clearly marked as to
everyone's benefit the residents of rye
and Newcastle the wildlife that lives
and breeds in these shallow Waters and
the PWC users who are generally
respectful and glad to know where the
areas are that should be avoided
these are the people who are
particularly concerned this all benefits
these individuals and these constituents
this pass unanimously last session and
was derailed due to covid the
constituents of Ryan Newcastle very much
want to see this past again
if you look at the map
that has it's kind of an expanded map
which particularly shows a protected
area
oh thank you Suzanne I had mine up oops
let me
um can you go to the other one
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's clear
do you have another one
that has the
does that make sense
let's work it out
one yeah that one
um the one that Suzanne had put up
before shows a larger area and even
again if you look at a larger map this
is a very small area this is in
particularly
the the best blow up that we have and
you can see
um
where the Blue Line starts
at the end of The Causeway between I
think that's now I forget if it's gold
Island and uh see that's not CV
and it goes around
um
those two big areas in the middle are
Pest and leech
and then I can't get down to the bottom
but perhaps you can it stops at the edge
of the bridge on the New Castle there
thank you on the New Castle side
um
the what were what we call the Wentworth
Rye Bridge
Vehicles can get under that bridge and
get out into the larger passage into
what's considered a little Harbor here
you can also see from there that they
can go up Sagamore Creek and go to BG's
and access all the whatever there is up
there
um so it's restricting just this small
area
from the bridge at the causeway on one
beat to the beginning of the Newcastle
Rye bridge in there it's a small air you
can see that there are a lot of islands
that ought to give you an idea that it's
a very very shallow area right now I
could lift up my laptop and put it out
the window and you could see that it's
basically totally mud flats right now
um
so that's pretty much all that I'd have
to say as I said it passed unanimously
last time people had a chance to come
out here and see what it's like if you'd
like I could lift up I could move my
laptop and look out yeah please huh I
got you back up I turned the maps off if
you could just avoid your camera out the
window that'd be great alrighty I I is
that working do I need to switch
something around or I need to turn the
computer around
okay
there you go tell me
what you're seeing
oh beautiful perfect
you got it
yep so that's the area you can see I you
can see the mud perhaps you can see a
very Wiggly channel in the middle which
is where lavender Creek comes out
um if we were lucky you'd see deer
walking across since it's a little time
does that seek does that help
yep
that helps a lot thanks a lot yes
okay
[Music]
okay and that's the uh that's the extent
of your testimony at the moment that's
it for now I'm glad to answer questions
but I go on it in
it it says
important to constituents here and that
in doing the research
um so many of the the bank of the
professional literature as you were as
you as you may have consider
um for personal watercraft users are
also very keen about sensitive areas and
to say mark it off so that they don't
they know that this is not where they
should go
um and you can see um just looking out
my window I guess it's a reasonably
small area when it is high tide it's
still shallow but it's very difficult
you know when you're on the water to
know how deep something is
I would help this to questions I think
um
any member
uh the committee uh are there any
questions for the
for the app
for the uh that they represent
seeing no hands
thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
on this bill
uh all right
a miles cook
this should be up now
hello can the committee hear me yes
thank you thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to speak
um and and I did get a chance to look at
this protected area that representative
Murray has proposed uh to ban all uh
personal watercraft from going into
um
she's she I I agree with with the with
the representative that uh that those
areas are sensitive and I do agree that
um
that uh that they you know they should
be protected in one way or another
however I I still my my understanding
these wave Runners that she's talking
about these watercraft uh the my my
extensive history with them and I've
been doing this for 27 years
um the wakes that they create are
significantly Less in comparison to
whatever boat might be traveling through
there not only that they do not have
lower units on them that they don't have
Rudders they don't have propellers uh
that protrude down into the down down
into the water uh you know sometime in
circumstances of such as three feet
which these are shallow areas and if
these propellers were to come contact
with the substrate they would cause
intense turbidity uh and you would see
the damage
um so the concern that I have is that
the looking in this area the message
that it's going to send is that this
this area has a lot of Moorings boat
Moorings
um a lot of people Park their boats or
I'm actually looking at a satellite
picture of it right now and I can see
all the boat Moorings in there
um people like to travel back and forth
to their boats using their wave Runners
uh using their watercraft
they will go through those areas and at
idle speed as they should which is the
law they have to go through their at
Headway speed they cannot create a wake
through there if they do it is already
an offense
um it is already against the law
so Banning the wave runners in that area
you know the concern that I have is that
the message is going to send and with
what the general population will will
learn is that they're just not welcome
here and while I do think that
Environmental Protection is important
the the structure of these watercraft
the way they're built if they're
operated lawfully
should and I and I say this with 27
years of experience should not be
creating the disturbance that the
representative is talking about uh they
should be creating a lot less
disturbance and represent a lot less
risk than boats in that area of which I
am looking at a mooring field that
probably has about 20 or 30 boats in
there that people will no longer be able
to go to their boats uh on their
WaveRunners to take a quick trip out
there to get something
um you know to to just hop on their way
runner go over there get something on or
off their boat transport back and forth
Shore uh they just won't be able to do
that anymore and you know
wave runners in those areas is something
that you know a lot of people that use
these products because the water is
relatively calm and it's relaxing and
there the those areas do access the the
BG boat house to get through there to
get to BG Boathouse you would have to
skirt those areas you could easily go
into one of those protected areas by
accident on a wave runner because she's
protected the whole area which goes to
those areas so
the concern that I would have would be
enforcement
um you know uh as far as you know
someone just taking a regular trip out
to their boat or going to somewhere in
the play one of the destinations the
businesses that they would go and visit
um
any of those purposes you'd be basically
Banning wave Runners now everyone would
have to go out and get a boat to do it
and boats have lower units they have
propellers they have
they they they're just they're
structurally they're a lot higher risk
to the environment and are the ones that
are creating the damage that the
representatives talking about
um so that's my concern and I just don't
fully understand how Banning those would
be beneficial to the environment
um given that you know they're just not
if they're a lot if they're operated
lawfully they would be creating less
damage to the environment than any boat
operating through there
any questions uh for uh Mr cook from the
command members of the committee
Susan Smith raise your enhancer
representative Smith smart question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question Mr cook
um I wondered if you had seen on since
you're on the call uh were you able to
see the map which shows the designated
area that would be closed off in the
back Channel yes I did what I did was I
when I saw it come up on my screen I
took a picture of it with my cell phone
so I have it here in front of me and I
can see your uh satellite picture as
well
yeah so
it seems to me when I'm looking at the
satellite picture that that area is very
very shallow anyway and I don't see any
Moorings I don't know what you're are
you looking at a picture from the summer
or well no you have to go to the north
uh you see leeches Island and pest
Island no no that go north give me a
second slide it down
there you go see that area right there
that see the where the 1B there's Goat
Island at the top of the screen and then
as you proceed to the left you see one B
that's that bridge right there that is a
main channel that most marine traffic
that passes through here goes through
and what happens is a lot of that Marine
Traffic will travel and you can actually
kind of see the channel
uh where it is you know in this
satellite picture it's actually pretty
telling because the mud flats are all
around and it gets really really shallow
in those areas but if you stay in the
channel you're okay and and um so if
you're you can already see a boat
traveling underneath the bridge in the
satellite picture uh under 1B that boat
is heading through the channel now if
you look at her protected area
um it is right there at the beginning of
that bridge
okay so if any Wave Runner were to pass
through there it would be very very easy
for one of those wave Runners to Veer
off to the left-hand side and go into
the protected area now where you're
bringing your mouse pointer right now
that's a large Channel area where there
are a lot of boats moored uh you can if
you go in there I don't know you're
counting 10 20 boats that are moored in
there so any person that owns a wave
runner that maybe live on the water in
Newcastle or live up in Portsmouth or
Dover or anyone that wants to go to
their boat now they can no longer do
that if you protect that entire area and
given that those areas are that that
area where those boats are more it stays
fairly deep uh it it just it it takes
out an entire it just it what it does is
it takes out the entire ability of
citizens to use that and to get back and
forth
thank you
any other questions for Mr cook
so you have two questions stand by
uh representative Cohen uh
representative Colin for a question
thank you um Mr chairperson thank you Mr
cook thank you very much for your
testimony I just need a slight bit of
clarification please
we talked about
um your observations and your
experiences for approximately 25 years
could you just let me know are you
coming to this as a soil or Marine
expert are you coming to this as a use
of the area a resident just what is your
experience open I can understand where
it's coming from okay so my experiences
in the use and operation of these jet
skis these watercraft but I also do
happen to have
um a pretty large amount of experience I
live up River in Dover and you know I
recently expanded my doc and uh I went
back and forth with the Department of
Environmental survey for services and
unfortunately we ended up having to go
you know into the court system and we
actually won and we were able to expand
our dock in doing that I learned all
about the turbidity issues created by
docking structures by wave Runners by
boats by by everything that's passing
through the area
um I had a chance to really you know to
meet with I've met with marine biologist
Adel fiorello over at Normandale
Associates I've met with uh Dory wiggin
a former Des official uh David Price DBS
officials David cadell Army Corps of
engineer officials uh I've had
consultation with Wetland scientists of
numerous different uh
surveying companies on the Seacoast so I
have you know some experience uh
learning about you know turbidity issues
Uh current issues uh environmental
issues that are you know that are in the
river I know about the eelgrass issues
that they were having in Great Bay I
know about the nitrogen levels that
Portsmouth and
um Portsmouth and Dover were being were
being uh reviewed for with regard to
their you know to what they were
discharging into the into the river
so I have some experience there I guess
enough to be dangerous but but uh most
of my experiences with wave Runners uh
boats uh and even Jet Boats as well uh
so remember they do have there are boats
out there that are powered the same way
as wave Runners have the same structural
makeup that wave Runners do
thank you very much Mr cook
I representative uh representative post
for question
uh yes
um thank you for testifying today Mr
cook and um thank you Mr chairman for
taking my question
um I wanted to ask you if the channels
are currently marked
um for low areas
um and not to come in during low tide
are you asking me yes I am okay uh there
are marks there there there are uh
markers in the channel however it is not
very well marked uh it's not hard for
for any boat or wave runner to
to uh travel outside the channel uh you
know by accident
thank you
is there any other questions or
representative Spang for a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question Mr cook
um I I I believe that you testified
um at our last hearing on this as the
owner of
um an Enterprise that sold these boats
is is that correct that is correct okay
my uh follow-up Mr Mister
thank you
um
I'm I'm pretty familiar with that area
because I'm a boater and um I haven't
seen very many people who access more
boats with a question please
can you please tell us how many
boats
assessed by one of these vessels
I actually I can't tell you all I know
is that there are a number of more
vessels out there I do know of people
that access their moored vessels via
Wave Runner we're watercraft and if this
law were to pass they would not be able
to
in that area
thank you Mr cook
are there any other questions for Mr
cook
sir I see no further questions uh there
being no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony is there
anyone else wishing to testify on this
bill
no one's hand rings
so you guys so being uh note that no
there is no one else wishing to testify
uh I will declare the hearing closed
I'll now go into a
full committee work session on House
Bill
184.
is there any discussion that we wish to
have on this bill so representative
Cohen this Henry's representative Cohen
for a question of your recognized Mr
chairperson Mr chairman give the count
from the blue sheet
uh right on the blue sheet now
for today's hearing
there are three people uh Kate Murray
who was testified Donna urbanic
a member of
addresses Newcastle and Robin Voigt
addresses Portsmouth and they are in
support
that is what's on the that's what's on
the white blue sheet
is there anyone else who might be signed
in representative Creighton later than
so you have uh
the nine people
Andrew Moore Barbara Moore in other
words nine people but they're not on the
blue sheet and looking to do they
express a an opinion no sir they don't
have their hand raised okay uh that's
the the blue sheet as we have it is uh
three people uh one of which has spoken
and two of which uh and all they are in
support
that answer your question representative
Cohen
yes thank you very much
yeah representative schmitzer uh
representative Smith uh for a statement
or a question or whatever yeah so we're
we are in the work session now Mr chair
yes we are yeah I'm I would like to hear
from Captain Dunleavy I see he's in
attendee
um as to the how the area is marked and
how people access their boats uh in that
back Channel and I see that Ted deers
from Des is also here and uh he could
talk about the uh the um the the
sediment building in the shallow Waters
etc etc if people want to hear from him
too
thank you okay all right uh Captain
Dunleavy uh you're you're there
good morning Mr chair and honorable
members of the r d committee uh
representative Smith thank you for the
question I can speak to the the general
navigational aides that are in that area
they are uh Federal
um markers in some places and some that
are installed by the New Hampshire Port
Authority the Marine Patrol does not
have navigation Aid jurisdiction on our
Coastal Waters but having first-hand
knowledge uh there are uh sporadic
Channel markers in the main Channel
um where you folks have seen by Goat
Island going down toward
um Wentworth by the Sea uh which is is
known as the back Channel
um the area specifically to Clampett
Island leeches those areas are are not
marked uh by by any specific Channel
markers
um and and part of that is due to tide
fluctuations and the ability for these
Channel markers to stay on station with
with those fluctuating tides
as far as your questions to sediment I
as as I was being given permission to to
to enter this hearing
um I I missed some of you the second
part of your questions for me
could you repeat your uh questions of
Representative Smith
yeah no the uh the sediment part was uh
going to be directed to Des if they came
on board
um but the the question I had was the uh
no we just heard from um a person who
testified about all the Moorings and
that people use often uh personal
watercraft to get to their Moorings and
they would not be able to get to The
Moorings if this law passed if this bill
passed and I just wondered um
you know how the people who
wore their boats there would be able to
access them
um thank you uh we see a variety of ways
that people access Moorings and and
specifically for that area along the
causeway out to Newcastle there are
several pull-offs uh we see people
launching all types of of craft there at
those pull-offs
um if you were to drive down there as
you approach Newcastle island in the the
cemetery which is the first property
that sort of greets you when you arrive
on the island there are numerous little
dinghies and row boats along the
shoreline there as well as row boats
with with outboard motors
um I have seen personal watercraft
access Moorings in the past uh not
necessarily in that area but that's not
to say uh that people don't use them at
those launch sites along the causeway uh
in in that fashion
thank you
uh are there any other questions from
members of the committee for Captain
Dunleavy
all right representative gunski and
representative
I mean all right perfect
thank you Mr chair uh Captain I'm
leaving
just a follow-up from representative
Smith's question
would this legislation have passed
prohibit an individual on a personal
personal watercraft from accessing from
the boring field in that area
yes as as the language that is proposed
would prohibit the operation of personal
watercraft in that designated area
so from basically from those maps that
you saw earlier that that uh blue line
that was designated uh if that is
included in the language of the bill
then we will post that area and and no
personal watercraft would be able to
operate at any speed in that area
for a follow-up
and that would be a follow-up I'm sorry
uh
so if we took a Headway if we
would it be possible to access that area
and no weight type condition
sorry
thinking about that
modifying the bill possibly
and uh
in your opinion would it be disrupted
for an individual to enter that area in
a no way tight condition
I can't speak to the environmental
mental impacts uh for the operation in
the shallow water when a vesicles at
Headway speed that's just outside of my
purview and expertise but I will say
that I believe it was a Mr cook that
that spoke earlier uh to other statutes
that are in place that depending upon
the tide and specifically where they are
in that that designated area
uh I would say that the overwhelming
majority of that area would already
require the boats to be traveling at no
wake speed just due to the approximity
from a shoreline whether it's an island
or the main Shoreline line of Newcastle
now certainly at low tide uh there's
more shoreline and and the lower the
tide the less area that they could
operate if they were more than 150 feet
from Shore
at high tide there might be a little
more water certainly deeper water for
them to operate but the majority of that
area would be in proximity to Shoreline
requiring Headway speed only
excellent thank you Captain
thank you
oh thank you chair um Captain Dunleavy I
just wanted some clarification on the
definition
um continuing in the same vein of
personal watercraft does that include
row boats
which is typical for accessing a boat to
a mooring
is that where
can you speak to that please thanks
absolutely thank you for your question
no it would not include rowboats
personal watercraft are uh defined as
being less than 13 feet in length they
must be jet propelled or powered by a
jet pump versus a propeller
and it is a type of craft that you would
sit on or straddle rather than sit in
like a traditional boat
thank you
sir representative post for a question
uh representative poster question
yes thank you again Mr chairman for
alarming the question and thank you Mr
Bellamy for um speaking up today
um and answering our questions uh I
would like to know if we are going to
protect this one area if that is going
to lead to all the other areas
um wanting to protect themselves in the
same way because when I look at these
um Google Maps
um it looks about the same in other
areas
um I don't know if those other areas are
currently protected and and this is just
an addition to that so can you speak to
that that whole inner area
stay there in the room as to whether
there would be restrictions for those
areas uh who knows I know that this
committee heard and and the legislature
passed a similar Bill a couple of years
ago for the uh the title flats and
marshes in Hampton and Seabrook uh and
this is a a similar Bill certainly our
Seacoast particularly as you go into
Great Bay and and up the piscataqua
river uh as well as as the areas around
Rye Harbor and and in the in in the
Seabrook and Hampton
there are tidal Flats up and down our
coast and so certainly there is similar
habitat that you're going to see in the
Newcastle channel that if if folks uh
and constituents wish to pursue this
type of restriction uh could certainly
do so
we'll follow up please or a follow-up
yes are there currently any risk
Universal southern area
in the other town
I'm I want to get the Piscataway River
and um up by round Island and
um that area
there are not the only ones we have uh
currently are are the the the marshlands
of Ryan I mean of Hampton and Seabrook
and and now this one uh that is proposed
before you today
thank you very much sir
any other questions
No Hands racing there being No Hands
thank you Captain uh chair would
recognize uh Mr deers
who is also a part of
uh representative Smith's question uh
representative Smith could uh you may uh
We've re-asked the question to Mr deers
that you were originally closed so I can
so the chair is able to catch his
ketchup I forget easily
its age
the um I was asking about the um value
of eelgrass and other uh aquatic plants
growing in the shallow Waters of the
marshlands along the Seacoast as well as
uh what happens when a jet propelled
craft goes through uh and and how
shallow and deep the whatever anyway
erosion and turbidity would be the would
be the concerns
thank you Mr chair can you hear me uh yo
uh can you hear me open here this little
bit uh could you also uh identify uh who
well you know yourself as far as your
expertise as well sure for the record my
name is Ted deers and I'm the
administrator of the watershed
management Bureau at the Department of
Environmental Services
um I have been with the Department uh or
the state for about 24 years I
previously worked in the coastal program
I was a coastal program director and for
about eight years I worked on salt marsh
restoration work uh in the Seacoast so I
am uh pretty familiar uh with the
marshes in and around New Hampshire
Seacoast so
um Mr chair members of the committee
it's a tremendous pleasure to be in
front of you today although virtually
and
um I appreciate the the question from
representative Smith
uh when I worked on I worked also on the
bill in Hampton back when that was going
on and I will just say that the the
primary issue that occurs relative to
the this issue of personal watercraft
out on the marshes is um it tends to be
really a high tide issue
so the the really fun thing to do I
think uh with a personal watercraft is
When the tide is very high it covers the
marsh
on an order of about 10 Tides a month or
so it fully inundates the marsh
and that allows for about to truly
travel
um pretty much wherever and and it's
really interesting it's fun I know that
I've been out on canoes and and such in
those kinds of conditions kayaks
where it's really fun to go places you
normally can't go
um and it is a tremendous expanse of
water
um I would imagine it allows you to have
um you know be able to go out and and
move around and and you know I don't
know exactly how that would relate back
to things like you know uh Headway
speeds when you see the entire surface
of the water is surface of the marsh is
actually covered with water so you know
at what point where are the channels you
don't know
um and but yet the marsh is really only
a few inches deep it's uh six you know
seven maybe eight inches below you
except on extremely high tides and so
certainly was the case in Hampton where
we had significant Marsh damage
occurring because of the jetting that
was going through those those jet Motors
out on the surface of the marsh and you
could actually you know there there were
I think Sue foot from from uh the uh
Seabrook Conservation Commission
testified that you could go out and you
could find places and the marsh had been
really torn up Marsh accrets at
something on the order of two
millimeters a year so if you dig a
couple inch hole in a marsh you can do
the calculations is how long that would
take for that to heal back up so marshes
are these are our living sort of
creatures more or less they're living
ecosystems that are um already under
stress they're in a stressful condition
that is they are you know inundated
twice a day and we also have advanced
sea level rise going on right now sea
level rise is about two or three times
what it has been over the past average
over the past thousand years or so and
so marshes are already challenged to try
to keep up with that
we also have challenges increasing
science showing that we have challenges
of nutrients that impact our marshes
this is certainly the case around the
Great Bay marshes where we see some of
those marshes having some deterioration
uh both as a result of excess new
excessive nutrients and sea level rise
so um certainly the protection of
marshes is really important they're
incredibly important ecosystems they're
rare relatively rare in New Hampshire
and they provide habitat to lots and
lots of Critters so um you know I think
for those reasons it's important to
protect them
um and certainly you know adding
additional wave action and agile
additional you know certainly those
certainly at those high tide issues is
really a challenge for the marshes
um make it clear that the department has
not taken a position on this bill I'm
just providing trying to provide a an
answer to what I've sort of seen and
learned over the years to representative
Smith's question
for a question thank you Mr chair uh
thanks Mr Peters for taking my question
just wanted to follow up on what we were
discussing earlier about the accessing
The Mooring field in a no-weight type
condition
if you give me your thoughts on what
type of disruption maybe a one of these
personal watercraft would have going
into a mooring field uh under no way
Commission
yeah I I I I can thank you uh
representative I appreciate the question
um certainly not my expertise in how uh
boats move around uh I'm not a boater I
would just refer back to to Captain
dunleavy's
um response that it totally depends on
tide
um
one of the interesting things uh being
out there and if it and I encourage
anyone who who really wants to have a
really enjoyable uh few hours uh of just
a little Marsh bathing is to really
watch how the how the how the tide comes
in and out
um it isn't sort of linear uh where you
have a channel that's there and it gets
smaller and smaller it really sort of
happens almost uh their their point in
some point in the tide it sort of
disappears and it would be at those
points where the where those Creeks gets
get smaller and smaller and you can't
really tell until they're essentially
gone uh where you start to have
challenges and as far as where the
Moorings are and where the docks are
that I I am not familiar with that but I
just think that it is very challenging
to to
um to know where you're at and how deep
things are in these Mars situations just
because they become very turbid uh at at
declining ties
thank you very much Mr representative
close to the question uh representative
post for a question
yes thank you again Mr chairman and um
thank you so much
um Mr Pierce for being here today and
speaking with us
um is I just wanted to clarify and I'm
not quite sure if you're hearing me
because I think the screen has frozen I
can hear you oh okay thank you
um uh are you saying at high tides it's
less destructive for those types of
personal watercraft to be using the area
or are you saying that's when the most
damage occurs
um thank you representative I think um I
was I was trained as an economic as an
economist so all my answers are it
depends uh that is the the time-honored
tradition as an economist that that is
the answer to all questions
so I will I will say it depends in as
you're in during the high as the tide is
coming up if you can sort of picture
this you have the channels that are
filling up with water
until it sort of spills over the top of
the channel and out onto the surface of
the marsh it gets deeper and deeper and
deeper and those channels would be less
likely to have erosion in them as they
get deeper and deeper and deeper so if a
TR if a you know some sort of a of a
vessel was moving through them
um it would tend to have less impact as
they fill up with water as they fill as
they go down you're going to have more
impact because it's going to be stirring
things up you have less you have more
more of that Shoreline exposed it's
lower you have undercurrents that come
up and eat at the marsh
now that that is true until you get to
the point until there's water until the
water actually goes all the way up over
the marsh and covers the marsh surface
with again it can be two three four six
eight inches of water and once you once
it's completely covered and TR and and
vessels can now Traverse the entirety of
the marsh that becomes very destructive
to have those Vehicles out on what would
be the flooded now flooded surface of
the marsh and I will tell you again I I
really encourage you sometime to put on
your Wellies and go out and walk around
on a marsh as the tide is is coming over
it as you walk through the you the mummy
chogs the sticklebacks these little fish
that are in there are just as you kick
your feet along in the water they're
just flying out of the water thousands
and thousands and thousands of them and
so it's a really again I really
encourage you to get out there and have
that experience
um it lets you understand sort of how
alive these uh these marshes are
thank you sir I appreciate your
clarification
let's not see if there's any more
questions
uh no other questions for uh Mr deers
thank you very much uh thank you
representative gumski you have a
question for the captain dunlevitt thank
you Mr chair tonight there seems to be a
little bit of concern that I put based
on the questions on Warrington give me
access to more information
all right it's under a low tide
condition would you normally access that
boring field
thank you representative for the
question
um certainly there are certain Moorings
that are in deep enough water where you
could be accessing them uh at all time
all tide cycles certainly there are
times where some of the Moorings on our
Seacoast and particularly in this area
where the boat itself that is on a
mooring is resting high and dry on the
mud flat or on the marsh so it all
depends on on the location of The
Mooring and and the water depth or how
close in proximity it is that that
Mooring is to the to the main Channel
thank you sir thank you
no one else
all right I'm sure you have uh
representative Smith from the question
representative Smith for a question of
Captain Dunlap yes thank you very much
and thank you Captain Don Levy
um
the you mentioned previously uh today
that the jet skis or the personal
watercraft have a jet propulsion system
and how does what happens to the you
know an outboard motor the water the
propeller shoots the water out the back
and then in a jet ski or a personal
watercraft what what as that happens
what's going on with the water that is
powering through
I don't think I'm saying it correctly
but
I I thank you representative I could do
a quick comparison
with an outboard motor a traditional
outboard motor or an inboard outboard
motor you've got the propeller that is
is spinning in the water providing
thrust
uh and and by turning the motor is how
you turn direction you're directing that
thrust
it is a very similar process with uh
personal watercraft in that instead of
the propeller
uh being exposed to the to the water and
and spinning providing the thrust
the jet pump simply has an internal
impeller they call it it's not exposed
but it's a similar device where it is
sucking water through the bottom of the
hull
going through this propeller system
and and and the water itself is then
being pushed out through this nozzle
it's a way jet pump and it is that that
thrust of water that is propelling the
vessel
and again the nozzle turns just like an
outboard motor
providing direction as you turn to and
from
in the case of of
jet propulsion
it is typically very directional
straight back from the machine there are
some slight angle changes on some of the
machines and more modern machines
we're an outboard motor you have what
you call power trim where you can you
can tilt it up and down electrically uh
depending upon uh what attitude you want
your boat to have as it goes to the
water and also to account for shallow
water you can lift the engine up out of
the water the jet pump is fixed to the
bottom of the personal watercraft
but it is it is the throat the thrusts
are very similar
thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much Captain
for a second time thank you very much
yeah all right you see uh no other
questions on this bill
I will declare the work session no no
no
representative Smith yeah I just wanted
to um clarify something
um representative post asked about
um would any other areas be affected by
possible future legislation and actually
this bill does include uh areas of the
Rye Marsh including Aquaman uh CV Creek
berries Brook Parsons Creek and those
areas are very very shallow uh
small tributaries and all come on Marsh
I don't think I've ever seen enough
water in it to be useful for any kind of
motorized boat
um but I just wanted to bring that to
attention that where the bill does
include other areas in Rye so it's
pretty much rye and Newcastle about each
other and so it includes other areas
there doesn't include the navigable
Creeks like Sagamore
is there any uh other representative
member of the committee who wishes to
make a comment statement uh based
basically part of this work session or
uh before I moved to Dollars before I
move us into executive session
representative Penske for uh comments
I think the basis
last year I voted for this bill
my concern
is that one point of accessing a morning
field if you are a homeowner in that
area and want to access a board field
with a personal autograph this will
prevents them representative gunski um
I'm having a really hard time hearing
you okay I will speak up louder how's
that yeah that's better thank you I said
representative Smith I have said that
that I voted for this bill last year
but more information has come forward
and my only concern is if I was a
resident in that area and I had a
morning and wanted to access that boring
with the personal watercraft I would be
unable to and it's apparent that
uh if you have a large vessel on a
mooring you need water to to keep that
vessel from
and to access that under a knowing
condition
I don't see
of a turbidity would be that much of an
issue just accessing a morning feeling
this bill prohibits that that's the old
that's the one hang up I have with this
bill
I'm sorry
um but uh to my understanding it it only
um prohibits jet propels
and not robots uh or is that correct I
mean typically people access
water yes
yes he said jet propelled yeah and that
is a general
Walker
yeah okay representative
representative
Mr chairman um I'm being a little
redundant here but I would like to
remind the committee that Mr cook was
unable to the answer the question of how
rare is the use of these vessels to get
out to a moored boat in my experience it
is much much more likely for someone to
just hop into a kayak or their row boat
it's a it's a short distance from the
shore out to these moored boats and um
as I say after 30 years of being on the
water I have never seen anybody use one
of these vessels to access
um a moored boat it might be a little
different here and but Mr cook seemed to
be unable to say that this was anything
more than fairly hypothetical
representative Kelly sir representative
Kelly for a statement or question or
whatever yes yes statement um yeah my
concern if we put any type of of uh you
know uh if we we uh you know put an
exemption for something or do something
along those lines that it will add uh
difficulty to enforcement
um it's very easy to put put signs up in
an area
um that that say no no personal
watercraft allowed within this Zone
um like there are for other boats in
other areas
um
it's very easy to do that and then for
for Marine Patrol or residents to to
know that somebody is crossing a line
uh
literally so uh you know it seems like
the the danger to the area is very high
um and the right like the as we can see
from the map it's a very small area
that's being Exempted so I think it'd be
much easier for us to just draw a line
um and let people on the other side on
one side use personal watercraft and on
the other have it restricted
yeah
representative Frank
thank you Mr chairman and get just to
follow on and
I agree with the bill
has written the One impact though
um as I'm looking at again the satellite
map the number of houses and I wonder
how many of those houses have jet skis
where the person bought a not
inexpensive house
with the express purpose of having
access to the water and now we pass this
bill and that access to water is now
denied
because he's got his jet ski ramp out in
the back that is no longer
he's no longer able to use because we
passed his law and I
as a landowner on water uh that would be
problematic to me
um no one has testified to that but
there's dozens of houses along there
will be impacted by this now
hello I love the question of uh again
captain
uh will this
will this bill if it passes deny people
who have
the uh those
those uh boats the jet skis
actually deny them access to the water
from their property
thank you representative yes as as
written uh regardless as to whether or
not a person owns Frontage along that
restricted area they would not be able
to operate personal watercraft uh from
their own property
and if I can share Mr chairman just a
for you I'm literally just looking at
the
at the uh
this is a house that will be impacted by
the end
and as you can see the the doc uh
extends out
he's got
at least a large fishing boat two kayaks
and then
looks to be what could be a personal
watercraft a jet boat and I'm not I'm
not sure with this picture
so I mean that's an impact on
people okay uh representative Smith did
you have a comment yesterday
or did you have uh no I did not okay
any other questions or comments
actually Mr chair
I was who's that
who is uh
looking at
um my satellite thing on my phone and it
doesn't appear that the piscataqua river
is within this
area
so that's the area right there
I just zoomed in on it
oh okay you see what I'm saying yeah
represent post for a question sir uh
representative post for a question
representative post
foreign
thank you very much for taking my
question
um my concern on this is not only will
be will we be restricting other people
but
um what I understood from Mr
um deers was that when the water was
higher it was not as damaging instead it
was just bad
well he also
um
spoke about
[Music]
um the nutrients coming in and I would
assume that would be from the homes
surrounding this area as well and I
I wonder if we're really trying to
protect this area if
um there should be more
um uh concentration on everything that
is contributing to the marshes
um demise over there so
um
was there a marine biologist or anything
that worked with the committee
um on this
foreign
does anyone know
[Music]
I think this is representative Smith I
don't know if a marine biologist would
be the authority on marshlands
I think of them more in like underwater
oceans and Bays whereas not in four to
eight inch deep Waters which is why we
we did talk a lot with uh Mr deers from
Des because he does have a lot of work
that he has done with the marshlands
along the Seacoast
representative Kelly
okay to quickly answer uh representative
close question we did receive the letter
from uh Professor Burdick at UNH
um talking who is a associate research
Professor for the Jackson estuarian
Laboratory
um who is in favor of the bill but my
main point of the statement was that
we've now held two public sessions for
this uh bill
um and the only resident of of Newmarket
who's who's come to the session has been
a representative who has spoken in favor
of the bill
um we've given people every opportunity
including two years of this bill to come
forward and speak about how it could
affect them personally and we have not
heard any so yes there might be that one
picture end of in the video but but I
was trying to go doctor doc to find one
as well I could not find one that was
clearly a personal watercraft
that'd be my main point
thank you
anyone else
anyone else for comment
before we go into executive sessions
all right I closed the uh work session
and open the this bill to Executive
sessions
uh
representative Smith uh Mo I recognize
you for a motion thank you Mr chair I
make a motion of ought to pass on House
Bill 184 and I would like to speak to my
motion when it's appropriate
uh let's do I hear a second
seconded seconded by
representative Kelly representative
Kelly uh representative Smith do you
like to speak to your motion yes I would
and thank you
um this bill has had a lot of work done
on it and because we kind of were asking
similar questions last year uh Captain
dunleavy's team out on the Seacoast took
us out on a field trip so we could see
the exact area we were talking about and
at the end of that we all understood a
lot better what we cannot really
understand just looking at satellite
photos and Mr deers commented about how
quickly the tide can go in and out and
you can be in a foot of water and all of
a sudden there's no water which can be a
huge problem and I had that experience
kayaking a few years ago in the Great
Bay where there was plenty of water and
I was paddling around and like within
minutes all of a sudden I was on a mud
flat and I was stuck for an hour until
the tides started coming in again so I
think this bill is important it's
important for the Ecology of the area
and representative Murray in her
testimony was quoting documents from the
um the personal watercraft industry
about how they recommend that they stay
out of shallow areas and I think that
this bill is a step in the right
direction
environmentally and for our Precious
marshlands on the Seacoast thank you
uh
Kelly what was that Kelly would you like
to speak to you second
wave
unless you'd like me to I
uh is there anyone else who'd like to
speak to
this motion
I would ask those who have had who have
expressed concerns
this on issue of
because
of its personal watercraft that might be
prevented from using
vehicle alone personal watercraft
we met their use during the rare times
that they need to take it out
from their property
is there a amendment that anyone feels
might
bring us closer to a consensus
to represent close to the question
representative post
you have a question uh yes
um i i two things
um
I I would make an amendment
um on that but my concern is on this
bill that we're we're trying trying to
preserve
this Marsh area but we're only looking
at one side of it
and I I just it targets one specific
vote vote I mean excuse me vote and um
you
um the representative just spoke about
how she got stuck on the marsh and I I
believe people with personal watercraft
when they see a low low area like that
aren't going to go in there and ruin
their boats
um so I'm concerned that we're not
looking at the whole picture here
the representatives saying thank you
yeah I'm not sure I'm successfully
lowering my hand but now that I I just
feel that we need to step back and and
look at the big picture here we have a
lot of information
scientific information about the impact
of these vessels on the marsh on the
other side we have no evidence that
there would be an adverse impact we
don't know if any of the people who live
around the marsh actually have one that
they want to use we don't know if
there's anybody who is using these boats
to access their moored boats so we're
taking a known uh harm that can happen
and has been observed and other marshes
and we're weighing it against
speculation that somebody might the
inconvenienced by passing this
legislation to me that's a very clear uh
path to a decision to pass this bill
[Music]
yeah I um
I appreciate that the hard work and the
thought that has gone into this
um
if I was a resident and I wasn't
involved in politics I didn't know this
was going on and I had a twenty thousand
dollar vote
on a million dollar house
and I had the legislature come up to me
and say hey
you got you can't use your boat in your
house
that would be a problem I don't know
that that exists represent US Bank I
agree I don't know whether that exists
uh potentially uh an endemic that would
say a grandfather Applause
they said those with boats in that area
as of the date that the bill passed
I don't know whether that's reasonable
or not but you asked for an alternative
Amendment
um and that would address
potentially some of Representative
dunsty's questions about those that
access the vote which again we don't
know how many that is it could be one it
could be zero I don't know
um I I just off that up to the committee
yeah representative Cohen
representative Colin for a statement
yeah thank you very much for recognizing
it I just wanted to address
um Representatives post comment I
thought she made an excellent point that
it would be good to look at the entire
problem here to protect the area
I would say that I would just suggest
that
if that's I agree with that look at the
whole area but this is a stepping stone
if we agree that what this does makes a
step towards what we want to do I would
just suggest we pass this bill and
consider in our next session next year
The Next Step that gets the com if it's
identity representative post can help us
and if it was a complete picture is get
the complete picture and amend the bill
next year but let's not wait a year to
do it is my only point there
representative
representative Kelly for a statement
back to the bill
yeah so I just uh to respond to
representative Creighton's um proposal I
just weary that if we add something
along those lines it'll be very
difficult to enforce and if we if if
other uh you know personal watercraft
users see somebody using a watercraft
inside that restricted area where the
signage is up it'll be
much more difficult for them to
understand the distinction between the
marsh and the greater piscataqua River
area
thank you
anyone else speak to well you have
representative Patsy sir
uh representative uh is it that that's
it
yes thank you for permitting me to speak
um I've been listening to the
conversation and it seems to me that if
you pass the bill and you have a couple
of homeowners that are opposed to it
that will uh clearly bring them out
um in opposition and at that point you
could consider an amendment it is my
understanding that we have passed other
bills in the past
um where we thought it was a good bill
uh it went into law and then we found
out that perhaps there were some things
we didn't think about and amendments
were then brought forward in future
sessions so since you haven't had
anybody opposed to the bill if you pass
the bill and there are people that are
um violently opposed with I think
um Representatives will be hearing from
them at that point and and then they can
consider future legislation to change it
yeah representative post
representative post for a statement
um
um thank you very much I I I'm still
it's more of a question
um having trouble with this because if
we are so concerned to protect this area
why don't we just ban all votes because
if they get in there during a time when
the tide goes out and they end up stuck
there they're going to be walking in
those marshes or trying to get someone
to come get them out
um and I just feel like this is
targeting obviously it is targeting
um and and I think if we really want to
protect it I think we have to put
um other boats in there I I think we
should Mark it as a restricted area
representative Spang for actually well
what would be is it a question or is it
I'd speak on the motion
representative Spang you recognized
representative spank on mute please
all right are we in the next session so
we can make statements or are we asking
questions we are made we are an
executive session we are to speak on the
bill if you have a question that you
would suppose in this way of a statement
uh on the bill that fine we're not
asking questions of anybody right yes we
are an executive assess each other dudes
me just fine
um this is our second hearing basically
on this bill
there have been plenty of opportunities
for people to come out who are uh who
would be adversely affected by this
um and we have not heard opposition so I
think for us to be making up uh
hypothetical opponents who are going to
be damaged by this is not
um addressing the uh the problem uh
rationally
um I would like to ask the chair
did we or did we not get a list of
people who were supporters of this bill
that included a lot of the people uh who
live in that area
no
the list that on the remote testify uh
ads list of three people that's that's
for today
I know there were people who were on a
list uh when we first had this right I
don't have that in front of me at the
moments I can't read that out and I know
that there were a lot of
letters and things that you should you
and everyone else should have gotten yes
uh so to be so everybody will know that
the number of people
so I would proffer then that this
indicates that it was uh this is not a
sneak attack that the people in the area
were well aware that this bill was out
and the fact that we've had no
opposition to it probably indicates that
uh that we're on firm ground in terms of
passing this bill
representative Smithson
representative Smith first uh on the
motion
um thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
um clarify uh representative post is
concerned that we're singling out the um
the personal watercraft but the
difference between a um a motorboat uh
and a or you know a regular outboard
motorboat and a personal watercraft are
as Captain I just Captain Don Levy said
that if you have an outboard you can
like pull the motor halfway out of the
water so it has a lot less draft and the
personal watercraft do not have that
option they're all set they're at the
set at the same setting all the time
just a clarification
yeah
anyone else which this big
there's a very cool thank you very
quickly
um I'm just wanted to say I'm I'm in
favor of this bill uh as a boater as a
kayaker and a sailboater and sometimes
using an outboard it seems clear to me
from my experience maybe I'm out of
touch but people typically don't access
their boats with a jet ski
maybe that that's probably quite rare I
think
um row boats or a small outboard a boat
with a small outboard is probably a lot
more common and just as a as a kayaker
and a person that enjoys these sort of
marshy areas
jet skis
seem quite out of place in them um so I
I just don't feel like we're
doing anybody any harm I don't think
that jet skis belong in these little
Estuary sounds and and marshes thank you
let's try some no further questions
no I'm sorry uh
representative Botley does her hand up
yeah I see what was that
[Music]
um
I just went back and tried to find
everything we got in support or if on HB
184 uh and I found four letters of
support from various people in the area
and nothing in uh against it
foreign
are we ready for
ready for a vote
yes
okay
we'll be on the motion of fought to pass
thanks representative gunski
representative gunski votes yes
representative Gould
yes
representative Gould votes yes
representative Horgan yes
Oregon votes yes representative harp yes
representative harp votes yes
representative Brighton representative
Payton votes yes
representative Creighton but yes
representative Dodge yes
Representatives Dodge votes yes the
clerk votes yes representative Healy yes
representative Mayville
representative mavo votes yes
representative Mayville votes yes
reference representative post
representative post votes yes
representative Smith representative
Smith votes yes
representative Smith votes yes
representative representative Spang
Senator Spang votes yes
Bank votes yes representative grassy
representative grassy votes yes
representative gottling representative
gottling votes yes
representative gottlings votes yes
representative Cohen Senator Cohen votes
yes
representative Connors
representative Connors votes yes
honors votes yes representative Vale
you who are
you
representative Vale
votes yes
bail votes yes representative Kelly
representative Kelly votes yes
hi representative Moran
representative Moran votes yes
okay representative Moran votes yes
representative debsey
yeah
representative
okay
representative gutsy votes yes
and representative renzu uh chairman
Zulu oh yes
that is 21 years motion tasks
fortunate consent
any issue what's been said objection
sounds good it is consent uh
representative Smith uh who is writing
the blur
um I'll be writing the blurb
you can move on yeah
to another bill we want but we have
if not we'll just simply
where the law uh you know continue it
until in the afternoon uh
I know there's a lot of people
interested in the house bill 229.
forward
I was Bill 229
[Music]
care recognizes representative gunski
for a motion
Mr chair I'd like to make a motion of
Ito on Coast Bill 229
maybe I have a second you have a second
from representative madeville
Mayville seconds
uh representative representative gunski
to speak on his motion thank you Mr
chair
uh have you been a member of the late
Club Commission
uh this is not a reputation that came
out of the commission you heard uh a lot
of testimony on this bill saying that
this is uh this is not a ban on weight
folks and that is correct this is not a
ban on weakness
so uh proponents
of this particular bill
have made statements that this is the
first step of some to come so there is
future legislation behind this bill to
make restrictions
I think during this time in the state of
New Hampshire where many families are
locked in their homes and some of the
only enjoyment they have are on our
Lakes I think restrictions are the last
thing we want to do
heads of that and obviously some other
things I think that this is a bad Bill
and it should be ideal
uh representative Mayfield to speak to
your second
thank you
um I agree with representative bunski
and I would just like to point out that
while the committee definitely
understands that there is an issue with
these type of boats that we do have laws
in place that already and currently
focus on the behavior of the voters
rather than the actual boat itself
um I agree this is an itl and expedient
to legislate
um that we do not need to Define and
ultimately regulate and potentially ban
this type of a boat that it's not good
for New Hampshire it's not good for our
citizens our Lakes are short little
Waterfront are really important to our
state and we should support those
activities as much as we can
thank you
is there anyone else who would like to
speak on the motion
I'm sure you have representative Smith
uh representative Smith to speak on the
motion yeah thank you Mr chair
um the Wake vote commission worked for
over a year to try to learn more about
them and uh and the effects that they
have on the environment on a budding
landowners and on people swimming in the
water and various other issues were and
the safety issues also we already passed
the wake surfing Bill and that was the
unanimous recommendation from the
commission when I introduced the idea of
defining wake boats at the Wake Boat
Commission the reason my reasoning for
thinking it would be a good idea to
Define them is because we had 20 over 20
people on the commission and the boats
were referred to as wake boats ballast
boats tow boats
um and
different people from different even in
the same industry referred to them by
two or three different names and I
thought that
um there I believe there is some
regulation needed and that if everyone
knew what a wake boat actually was
and up until I served on the commission
I was not even sure what a wake boat was
or what one looked like so I thought
defining wake boats would be a good idea
um I am not the prime sponsor of the
bill I'm one of the co-sponsors but
um I believe that defining the boats
does not necessarily mean regulating
them although there are certain areas
like similar to the marshlands that we
just talked about in the last bill and
shallow areas of lakes and shallow coves
where some regulation may be needed
further than the 150 foot Zone that we
now have as a buffer
thank you
representative
representative Kelly for uh to speak on
the motion
yeah so to follow up on representative
Smith's points I I agree I like the the
definition of wake boat does not mean a
band I do not support a ban on Wake
boats
um but as a a CDL operator a wake boat
is every year uh the Wake boats will
continue to increase the amount of
ballast that they produce as to as
engineering and Technology go along it
is important I think it's important that
this committee look at them as we go
along that route just as a CDL operator
I have to go through additional testing
to operate a truck over the gross weight
of 26 000 pounds I think that as these
ballasts get larger and larger it is
important that they need it may become
um it may become necessary for this
committee to issue additional permitting
for those who wish to operate them so
for a driver increasing the age to 21 or
something along those lines and that
would require a definition of the boat
itself again I don't support an outright
ban obviously I think we've also said
that at some point during this committee
but just as we have larger vehicles that
require special licensing a a additional
ballast in the boat that could
potentially cause greater harm by
mistaking mistakenly operating it in a
certain way may require
additional
you know licensing or additional
training that's my only point
you know anyone else we should speak to
the building so there are no further
hands-ups
representative Botley got her hand up as
well who is
the residence
to speak
uh yeah uh one of the things I would
like to point out is that uh
when I spoke on this bill not two years
ago three years ago
um
I I presented uh information that uh
the amount of ballast that's being put
in the boats is just increasing and
increasing and increasing and I have an
advertisement for one that well we heard
about one
um where there was 2 800 pounds of
ballast but I can find other
advertisements of up to 5 000 and then
even saying oh no we can give you six
thousand pounds of ballast so I think
that is being promoted in the industry
and every time you increase the amount
of ballast you are basically increasing
the amount of weight and so uh
you know I'm simply speaking to that uh
representative Kelly uh in support of we
may have to think of things in the
future that uh help out a bit
okay uh representative is there any
other representative for the first time
representative okay representative
grassy for the first time yeah I'm I'm
going to be voting against this motion
because I feel it's important one of the
things that we listen to is we say well
people want to enjoy our Lakes
and when you look at the environment the
natural environment that we have here in
the state of New Hampshire that's the
true New Hampshire advantage
and we've looked at a number of
instances and not just wake boats but
other things such as ATVs and everything
where
we've seen a significant amount of
environmental damage
and to make the parade off that it's
okay to damage the environment because
people are enjoying themselves
seem to doesn't seem to fit I think we
we can do both
and by defining weight boats we're able
to provide sensible regulation
that maybe a wake boat on certain lakes
or ponds is not a place to be
maybe we need to increase the distance
from the shore
because of the damage these boats are
doing
just say let them do their damage we
don't care
um eventually the advantage that we have
here in New Hampshire is going to go
away because we'll have destroyed it
I think this is the wrong time to just
say no to this maybe it's something we
want to retain
um or uh and take a longer look at it
instead of just saying no so I'll be
voting against this motion and we'll
hopefully uh we'll be able to retain
this bill maybe work on a little bit
more we need to do something
we just can't say that because people
want to enjoy themselves
the heck with the environment let's just
let it be destroyed because Pat you know
people are having fun destroying the
environment
representative
representative post for the first time
yes um thank you Mr chairman um I
support the itl and this is why when you
look up ballast anyone can add ballast
to a boat so how can you define that how
will they know whether it's a a cooler
placed in a certain you know filled to
the brim with heavy weight to make that
effect and I think that puts a real onus
on Fish and Game or whoever has to uh
follow you know uh these votes to decide
and somebody might inadvertently have a
cooler on one side that all of a sudden
now they're being charged with something
because or given the fine because
um uh they have a a wake boat and so I
feel like this definition
um is is not well uh grounded and
um
I I think it doesn't include just one
class of boat like a jet ski
um this includes all boats
um because everybody can modify to be a
ballast so I support itm
representative Titan for the first time
uh yes Mr chairman thank you just to
follow on representative post I'm just
reading the bill what it says it says
any vote
is equipped with ballast tanks bags
compartments Etc
that are designed to alter or enhance
the characteristics of the boat's wake
so the way I read this my kayak
with a cooler in the back could malt of
the way to my kayak and then fall under
this definition
and so I just think that
it's not making a lot of sense to me the
way I read it
um if I don't know how I would apply
that across the board
uh no other person for the first time on
representative standby
sir you have uh represented Kelly and
representative Harmon her first
representative harp for the first time
it's thank you Mr chairman uh I Echo
some of the comments of my fellow
Representatives about the definition
being expansive but I also want to say
that I was persuaded by the hundreds of
emails I got from boaters that suggested
we ought to look into more education and
I'd like to see us
figure out how can we do that for the
people that do have what I would
consider a wake boat rather than setting
a definition so I will be supporting
um IDL thank you representative Kelly
first uh
representative dunski put the second
time followed by representative Kelly
thank you Mr chair
I I much like representative harv I just
want to follow up on what he stated I
want the committee to uh to recall we
had over 1200 in opposition that signed
in on the bill originally
and about 130 135 that are supporting
the bill so it was over 10 to one when
we heard when we first heard this bill
in proposition
there has been many discussion about
this isn't yes this is a definition
and I heard restrictions maybe some
changes mic slight changes this is just
as I said in the past this is the canvas
knows Under the Tent
I don't think this is necessary as
representative Harvard had mentioned
about education there is an education
program that has been that the industry
has been working on diligently called
wake responsibly the industry local
marinas are on the Marine Patrol
to to
develop a campaign to educate voters
I've talked about education I because I
talked with with several individuals
including people that are on this bill
they they laughed when I talked about
education like are you kidding me you
think education is going to work and I
think that's wrong education does work
it's proven in many areas throughout the
state where it has worked and I think we
should be focusing more on the education
of the voter instead of the legislation
do you have representative Kelly
representative Spang and representative
post all right representative
representative Kelly followed by
representative Spang
LED and by representative postal for the
second time
representative Kelly to speak thank you
Mr chair my question I guess is I'm a
freshman rep so I'm still on clear what
emotion of what voting for emotion of
itl mean that we are unable to examine a
new definition
um in the next two years I guess my
because my concern is like I believe
that this definition is wrong just like
representative Creighton said I think
that it does needs a little bit it needs
to be flushed out more but I would like
to
do that and I just don't know if an itl
motion would mean that we couldn't
examine it further down the line what an
itl motion basically does is an
expedient to legislate and if that is
passed by the house then it uh it would
ostensibly
be dead however uh something
a bill similar to this that it is or but
another bill can come forward in the
second year if there is if there's
enough significant difference
uh there could be a or could be a
similar bill
passed that really a lot of that similar
build brought before this committee uh
and in fact
I've seen it I've seen it done a lot of
it depends about on the speaker
and maybe the chair of this committee
beyond that uh advantage or question
yeah so thank you Mr chair
um
followed by representative post for a
second time
thank you Mr chairman
um first uh in response to
representative I can't quite hear you
everybody here well
okay talk louder oh it says okay
um an alternative motion which would be
to refer for interim study and then that
would give us the opportunity to do what
he is talking about doing
uh
interim study is only allowed for its
second year I'm sorry I mean retain okay
so if we turn down the
itl we can make a lot of paying the bill
and then we would be able to study uh
some of the issues that representative
Kelly is talking about
um I
I I'm not sure if it's appropriate to
say this but I am really disturbed by
the committee uh getting thousands of
letters uh
commenting on a bill with misinformation
or with a misunderstanding of what the
bill does we're going to be seeing
another bill later where that is being a
problem where we have interest groups
who get people to write
um in opposition to a bill with
information that is not true
in this instance I think it's very
obvious that um
that we are taking a bill and projecting
what might happen in the future
which is always
a poor way to do our legislation we can
take this definition and clearly the
definition could not apply to a kayak
because you wouldn't be putting a
coolant cooler in to increase the wake
but if there is a problem with the the
wording of the definition then I think
that Representatives Kelly's
solution is where we should be going
with this
thank you Mr chairman
uh representative post for the second
time
uh yes thank you Mr chairman
um I I just wanted to
um Echo uh representative denske's um
petition that Education Works and I will
say that because we all wear our seat
belts we wear ski helmets we wear bike
helmets I think most of these were never
mandated before we all started using
them for our own safety and knowing that
these were good things and I think when
you educate
the Boating industry on what happens
with excessive ballast
will work because people want to
continue using our waterways and I think
if they you know that's a good solution
without legislation
all right representative Colin go right
ahead yes quick question just for
clarification from you could you please
explain exactly what the procedure would
be if we wanted to offer a motion to
retain this bill do we need to
um
you have the the itl has to be defeated
itl has to be defeated right yeah I've
done it with the itl it would have to be
defeated then you could bring someone
could bring Floyd from motion to retain
okay thank you very much for the
clarification thank you uh I just want
my I would like to speak uh on the bills
the chair's privilege
uh I am going to support the motion
uh
for a basic reason the bill is far as is
fundamentally flawed and and is in a lot
of overreach uh
we're
the issues that we're facing on this is
not so much a boat
as it is the enforcement
there is there are other issues there
are there are important issues
that we should take in the and
I feel that and the chair will commit
to work to put together an ad hoc
committee
uh in this in this uh
well in in this committee and ad hoc uh
committee to be able to examine some of
the
issues that need correction I mean
especially in the area of enforcement
uh and in the in the area of education
but these things have to be have to be
legislative scalpers not Hammers and
this is a legislative Hammer so uh it
right now this bill uh I've I've been
convinced that
uh it it is put a cloud over these the
use of
a whole lot of boats
for sales in in the state and I don't
think we want that
I think what we want to do is to have
precise builds to
to fix and correct precise issues so I
will be supporting
the itl
but I also like I said as I say I will
be committing to
push forth amongst this committee uh
ad hoc effort to be able to put forth
bills
from members of this committee
for the second year
that will correct certain issues we'll
try attempt to correct the issues around
wake boats
but that
I will because there'd be no further
questions
will the clerk please call the roll on
the motion of itl in expedient to Legacy
thank you chair representative gunski
representative yes gunski votes yes
representative Gould yes
called votes yes representative Horgan
yes
Oregon votes yes representative harp yes
representative harp votes yes
representative frightened representative
yes Brighton bets yes representative
Dodge
yes
representative Dodge votes yes
clerk votes yes representative Healy
illegal yes
Healy votes yes representative Mayville
representative mava votes yes
Abel votes that yes representative post
representative post votes yes
not most votes yes representative Smith
she uh president Smith you're on mute
still on mute representative Smith votes
no
representative Smith votes no but
representative Spang Senator spank votes
no
representative Spang votes no
representative grassy representative
grassy votes no
representative grassy votes no
Representatives uh gottling
representative gottling votes no
representative Cohen
representative Cohen votes no
Cohen votes no representative Connors
representative Connor's votes no
representative uh Connors votes no
representative Vale
planet of Vail votes now
bail votes no representative Kelly
representative Kelly votes yes
representative Moran
a representative Marine Bush yes
representative Moran votes yes
representative dutzie
representative gutsy votes no
representative Dusty votes no and the
chair uh folks yes
okay
13 gays
and one two three
eight Nays motion masks
uh will there be a Minority Report
I'll figure that out
uh either it'll be me or someone else
but there will be a Minority Report
yes definitely okay so right now uh the
minority Court yes uh
and you'll get back to me with who
but who will do it yes Mr chair
and and for a majority report will be
the representative
okay thank you very much
we have enough time to continue
executive session psychology
executive sessions
pick it up again after
Hospital 446 which is live at one
o'clock uh right now we're in let's see
we've got one minute
and we'll be into house bill three
79 if anybody wants us
excuse me it's my dyslexia again
my glasses
I just
sorry I just had a I just had a screen
freeze
um I wanted to check and see because I
had a screen freeze before on the first
vote on um
that we had
representative post I was at a frame
screens
can I get the numbers from the first
vote
the first vote yes
it was unanimous okay I I had a screen
freeze then too thank you
I'll tell you if you have a screen free
sometimes just turning off your video
will help because it sometimes maybe
you're bandwidth and having video you're
using a lot of bandwidth so just turn
the video off and it usually helps thank
you
all right
it just stepped out okay
[Music]
and then we'll start off
there are some 397 bills
thank you
[Music]
um
yes 397. yeah
okay I I got um
so I have that here
so I was confused fine
it's just allowing that
properties
serial cartilage
so
it's
a matter of time thank you foreign
[Music]
yeah
sir uh representative Pearl are you
there
you go
all right can you hear me okay yeah
there are you don't you know the drill
as far as
phone number
you know you know what you know what you
want other people to say in front of
your committee do the same
thank you Mr chairman
my internet's acting a little funny
right this minute so hopefully we're
okay here can you hear me okay yeah we
can hear you right now if you don't feel
all right let's go with it
okay go go right you're on
I'm going to turn my video off because
if that's okay because mine seems to be
skipping all right why don't why don't
you turn it off then that's fine
all right let's try that okay well good
morning members of the committee uh for
the record my name is representative
Howard Pearl from our Merrimack 26
representing the talents of Loudon Law
School in Canterbury Northfield and
Franklin Ward 3. I am here today to
introduce house bill 397.
and uh I sent you some notes with my
talking points so I won't cover all of
it because uh I know you're always short
for time but I'll try and hit the points
that I've highlighted in my testimony I
sent forward
this bill reinstates a fee exemption
that was in place until just two years
ago when it was allowed to Sunset it's a
pretty simple one-line bill and I have
an amendment that I'm going to introduce
and and once I do it the amendment will
stay permits for projects solely funded
by Municipal County state or federal
entities shall be exempt from the
permitting fees of paragraph one
so what I was approached by some of the
municipalities and uh talking about the
high fees that they have which can run
into the tens of thousands of dollars
for these permits and up until a couple
of years ago they were exempt from them
until the uh that exemption sunseted
there was a uh this this bill or a
similar bill that had some of this
language and it was in the Senate last
year uh Senate Bill 491
and it had gone through the Senate
unanimously and became a uh became a
victim of the pandemic and so it did not
end up coming through to the house
I know Des has had some concerns with
this bill but this uh this would be
consistent with other areas that they
have exemptions in the On Solid Waste
such as uh you know facility permits for
political subdivisions sludge uh quality
certification fees and towns who haul
their own sludge are exempt from fees
I think most the most important point
right now is the pandemic has certainly
put a lot of municipalities and
financial crunches and you know
reinstating this exemption for them
would would be come at a really good
time for any of them that have any of
these projects that are moving forward
um I want to say to note that the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and the
New Hampshire Water Works strongly
support this legislation and you'll be
hearing from some of the other uh
municipalities that will testify behind
me and I think probably most of the
technical questions they'll do very well
answering more so than myself
I I guess I'd like to talk about the
amendment here just quickly at this
point so if all of I emailed it to the
whole committee and that is amendment
2021-0579h and all this amendment does
is simply removes the uh
the exemption for uh
the non-profits I understand there was
some concern in that area with some of
the committee members about how broad
that language was and I agreed I think
the most important part at this point is
we get that exemption back from the
municipalities in the in the state or
federal entities so I would introduce
this amendment and again it just simply
removes the uh
those non-profits from being in the
exemption
I would uh I guess that's pretty much
all that I really want to cover and and
I I appreciate the time of the committee
and I'll certainly answer any questions
and again if you've got some real
technical ones I I think I'll ask you to
ask those of the folks that are going to
testify behind me from the
municipalities
any questions of Representative Pearl
so we have representative
representative colon for a question
thank you very much for taking my
question
um is there a financial impact with this
amendment I didn't see one I didn't see
them or the attachment
uh there was not a fiscal note attached
to it that's correct
follow-up Mr chairperson or follow-up
why wasn't there I'm not objecting to
the bill I'm just concerned on the
impact on the state uh of the bill
I'll be honest with you I do I I don't
know why the I guess no one asked for a
fiscal note on it and I'm not a uh
I don't know what the Des would have to
ask for that but uh usually when it goes
through the process they'll put one on
if they feel it's necessary so I guess
they didn't didn't see the need for one
on this
okay thank you you're very welcome
thanks for the question
yeah any other questions of
Representative Pearl sir represent
representative post for a question yes
thank you Mr chairman and um thank you
our representative Pearl I just wanted
to confirm that um
uh
sorry I'm having a brain freeze day in
addition to my computer
all right I'm gonna have to wait for a
minute until my brain starts working
again I apologize
right I'm sure you have no further
questions I like uh we uh we'll move on
that's our representative representative
Spang for our question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you just speak louder
I really can't hear you you're gonna
have to yell into your phone into your
uh
is this better
louder would be better
due to this computer to make it louder
I can hear you
okay that's what matters no no suddenly
we heard you
but continue okay representative
representative Pearl maybe you can pass
along what I'm saying to the chair
um my question is when I looked up the
RSA that this is being embedded in it
seems to just relate to the permit by
notification
um
projects right were you aware of that
that it doesn't apply to any of the
other Wetland uh permits
yeah this is pretty narrow actually and
um it's done so intentionally and it
targets just the specific permits that
we were looking to get exemptions from
so following up Mr chairman for a
follow-up yeah so and and maybe Des can
confirm this so these are the projects
that are have very minimal impacts so
the ones I would think the ones that
would be uh more expensive were the more
expensive permit fees would not be
included in this bill is that correct
representative Pearl
I think I'm actually going to defer you
to Des to answer that question you're
going to get into an area that's a
little bit beyond my technical knowledge
so rather than give you the wrong answer
I think I'll ask you to ask them that
question thank you representative
well thank you for the question
uh representative post for our question
thank you very much Mr chairman and I do
have my question written down now I I uh
representative Pearl I wanted to know if
you gave a Sunset date when that
happened and is that possibly the reason
why
um it didn't go for fiscal note that it
was recent
I honestly don't know why it didn't go
for a fiscal note we did not put a
Sunset date on this it did Sunset two
years ago uh I guess that's something
the committee could certainly consider
if they wanted to add that to it but uh
I don't I didn't feel it was necessary
so I didn't put one on
this is the exact Language by the way
that that was in the uh RSA prior to at
sunsetting the original bill now that
we've removed the um the exemption for
the non-profits then it'll be slightly
different but that'll the original 397
that I put in was the original language
that was in before
may I give a follow-up
for a follow-up yes um do we know
um what kind of what it cost us in the
past
is there any
um accounting for them
I think that would be a better question
for Des and I guess it would depend on
what projects that were currently in the
pike
thank you
you're welcome thank you for the
question any other questions uh
there being no other further questions
thank you very much
thank you I appreciate your time uh
let me see
yep well I have
uh might as well go with the go with the
but with the Mr Pelletier from
representing the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services an
opposition to the bill to testify
all right so he's transferring
spell it too
are you there
it's coming up
can you hear me we can hear you oh
perfect
yeah I think we we oppose the bill
because uh but this belt here first of
all just to say your name your uh what
would you represent what uh
no okay
Etc I know I know but a lot of some
folks here though okay uh Rainey
pelotium the assistant director of The
Water Division the Des uh and obviously
Shoreland is one of the programs within
the Water Division out of the seven
major bureaus that we have so I'm here
today we we spoke uh did not support
this bill because of the financial
implications I think philosophically the
department
uh opposed this because we thought it
was somewhat inequitable for the normal
resident of the developer or other folks
to be paying a fee and as you know Chief
renzullo the shoreline program is
totally fee funded uh it's a fee for
service program and we felt that it
while uh public projects used to be
Exempted and representative Pearl I do
appreciate your Amendment uh I think
that
brings us some concern less concern if
you will
um one of the thoughts we had now that
you've
brought forth that amendment is maybe an
approach might be because of the fee
structure
is based on
funding Staffing so we can meet our
statutory turnaround times so that's why
we have concern about when you get
exemptions I think I was asked one of
the questions in 20
last year we received fifty thousand
dollars worth of fees in from state in
local municipalities 22 000 of that fee
was from dot for a Bridge Project so
there is a fiscal impact albeit it's not
thousands hundreds of thousands it was a
concern
um so that's really the long and the
shot of it is that's why we didn't
support it because we are fee based and
that's what supports our staffing which
is critical to us because we we have
mandated turnaround times on
applications
I certainly would be willing to take any
questions or thoughts uh I do have one
thought though before I
go away is perhaps we can look at what
representative Pearl is presenting and
maybe put a cap on those applications
they used to be a thirty seven hundred
dollar and fifty thirty seven hundred
and fifty dollar cap on applications
until 2018. uh that may be an approach
that would uh take a little bit of the
bang out of the lack of Revenue uh just
something to think about
represent expansion
Representatives bank first question
thank you
Mr chairman and Mr Pelletier
um you know I'm a I'm very sympathetic
to des's
um increasingly uh dire circumstances
uh fiscally
um
so I hate to ask this question
but is it a possibility that the fact
that this applies only to pbn projects
which are ones that I would think would
require less
involvement a lot fewer resources from
the agency does that help to reduce the
impact
on your uh on on your budget
uh
uh representative Spang I I don't
understand the bill to just deal with
pbns uh perhaps representative Pearl
could uh uh speak to that
if obviously pbns are 400 per
application that is a significant
difference than a 400 base fee and 20
cents per square foot
um but again I didn't understand this
bill to just speak to pbns
chairman I'm looking
a set and it's at 483 B 5 b
which is
um the section that is entirely devoted
to pbns so I assumed that it was just
relating to the 20 cents per square foot
and the
um 200 or 400 dollar base
uh for the for the pbn projects now I
don't think I think this bill is written
applies to all Shoreland applications
both pbn and standards
the 20 cents per square foot is is not a
pbn a pbn fee is a flat four hundred
dollars I'm just looking at where it is
in the rsas
um and it seems that the whole that
whole paragraph Just relates to defining
a pbn and talking about what is
necessary in an application for a pbn
and then the fees
um representative Mr Pelletier
um
if if the agency feels that a
that a fiscal note is appropriate for
this bill is the agency
uh unable to independently ask to
prepare a fiscal note even if the OLS
does not
or the committee does not
disability are you there
we lost him
he's fled
maybe somebody was there
this is Mr pelletier's common reaction
to me when I ask a question
okay he's a back Mr Solitaire it's
everybody's common reaction to you
Judith
representative
can you please dabble that man down
not me
uh Mr Pelletier are you there
I think he's having trouble
are you ready
uh can you hear me can you hear me now
we can hear you now yeah I keep uh
getting a thing that says rejoin keeps
coming up in front of me so if I might
chairman renzuelai there's two questions
two parts to that question the first
spot is on the uh Shoreland fee 483 b5b
is all permits not just pbns just add
Clarity to this so as far as we're
concerned this bill applies to austral
land applications
secondly the fiscal note generally comes
over to us from administrative Services
when they look at a bill and determine
that there is potential for fiscal
impact uh to state local or County uh we
did not receive a fiscal note as you can
tell by the dialogue that's taken place
here this morning there is a fiscal uh
path to this legislation albeit it's not
hundreds of thousands of dollars
[Music]
um
but I I again I like representative
Pearl's uh amendment I think that makes
sense it makes it more equitable
um and I guess I could certainly live
with the other part of the bill which
talks about public benefit projects if
you will municipalities and so forth uh
but I'd like the committee to entertain
perhaps on those four
applications that uh
representative Pearl has in the bill
that maybe we put a statutory cap
which used to be there prior to 2018
of 3 750 it does take more of the sting
out of the fee loss but I think that
would be uh I feel pretty comfortable
with that being a good compromise for
the agency
right and a follow-up uh I don't know
whether this is for Mr chairman or Mr
pellets thank you
um would this require that we retain the
bill in order to work out that that
compromise language uh
if someone decides to bring an amendment
to the amendment
uh or somewhat in other words
take uh
Amendment 2021
0579h and adding a statutory cap to it
uh voice what did you say 37 50.
37.50 yep that used to be the cap uh and
that could be taken up
in the after uh in the afternoon
executive session it would require
someone
to call
OLX up the OLS to get that
drafted and sent to us
is anybody going ready to do that
I'm sure you have representative Pearl
you said Pearl has his hand up okay
representative Pearl
thank you Mr chair if that is the will
of the committee I would be more than
willing to take that to OLS and have it
done for you uh why don't I just take a
just a general consensus not a vote for
the general consensus of the committee
so you have two hands up
um Smith and folks all right uh
representative Smith
did you uh you can't hear you're on new
I was going to suggest that because so
much new information has come into light
uh such as what the bill actually
applies to a possible cap taking out
non-profits I'd be questioning why are
why is the federal government in there
getting a pass
um that that I think that's a lot of of
stuff to put into an amendment a fast
turnaround Amendment and I would think
it'd be more beneficial to retain the
bill but that's going to come up later
for a comment yes thank you um this is
actually a question
um I'm a newbie and I do not know what
pbn is
can anyone answer that
can you hear me yep yes yeah uh permit
by notification is a fee that it's a one
flat fee of 400 for projects that aren't
major and impact and uh those uh
somewhat common for projects that are
under 1500 square feet of uh impact
so it's a process that's used readily
follow up please
representative uh representative harp I
think
you know every representative poster do
you have a follow-up yes I just wanted
to know if it proclaimed uh specifically
to the Shoreline
yeah
the Shoreland program involves any
activity that's taking place from the
mean high water mark back 250 feet from
the shoreline
that is what the show in or the water
quality act uh has regulations on
thank you I appreciate that
is that hard to followed by anyone
expand and code
uh representative harp and thank you Mr
chairman uh following up and
on representative Smith even with the
cap I would be concerned about how what
is the fiscal impact even with that cap
since it's a feed-based uh operation so
I'd be asking for a fiscal note on it uh
I think maybe retaining might be the
best thing because I appreciate the uh
potential exemption of cutting out the
federal government being free from any
promise thank you
in Spanish uh representative Spang for a
second or third time
I believe it's the fifth that's what I
figured but ran out of fingers
go right ahead my question
um is I I'm intrigued by the idea of not
letting the federal government off the
hook
um and I'm uh wondering what the fiscal
impact would be I think you've said that
the the D.O.T but that state but what
would be the the impact if we were to
not exempt the federal projects and
um and uh and then my question would be
to the chair whether that whether the
committee would agree to slipping that
into our uh Amendment also to remove the
exemption for the federal projects
and maybe Mr Pelletier can help me with
that
uh
committee can do a lot
uh at what point does it become
cumbersome first of all if the committee
is demanding a fiscal note that doesn't
happen today
that I the committee has to vote on that
and he would have to go to have to be
submitted to the uh the office to and in
order to get a fiscal note uh and there
are the other things we can all we can
we can work on but if we continue to
keep finding stuff
[Music]
asking for Stuff eventually it becomes
unworkable for an amendment today
I'm sorry
right now we're positioned to amend to
you could will amend to the uh the
the amount of money the 3750 fairly
readily
Federal entities and if you want to
discuss uh
other issues
then it becomes more cumbersome
so just be aware
we want to do something with this bill
today
Mr Pelletier and representative
uh
uh Mr Pearl representative Pearl first
is your bill
yes hey thank you Mr chair I'm just
trying to make sure if I'm clear I I
would have no issue amending the bill
with the 3750 cap and removing the feds
I really think I I don't disagree with
the uh the sentiment that's been raised
I think he Municipal County and state is
the most important parts of this bill
and so I I would be more than willing to
do that I I will throw in um I had a
bill in my committee where I was in a
similar situation to yourself that I
reached out to uh Mr alakonis to request
a fiscal note I was informed that I was
not able to get one until it had passed
the house to get a revised fiscal note
so I will just throw that information in
there all right if that helps the
committee
so I guess my question is do you want me
to go forward with an amendment with the
3750 cap in removing the federal part
well we'll we'll see where we're going
from here uh Mr pellets okay
yeah I just I
can you hear me yeah
I just like to know what I I think uh
it's it's it's refreshing to see
representative Pearl be willing to make
those changes I also will say that at
this point I believe it's important if
this bill does pass uh we do have
Municipal projects coming up on the deck
we also have dot projects coming up on
the deck
um I think with the cap that makes it
more palatable for us I would Advocate
that the committee entertain
representative Pearl's willingness to
put in those amendments but um candidly
I don't think fiscal notes necessary now
that we've gone through this dialogue
and talked about applications fees as I
said last year 20 and 20 there was fifty
thousand dollars worth of Revenue
um again 22 000 of that was with DOT
projects uh but I think the department
would feel comfortable with the an
amendment as proposed by representative
Pearl and I do uh thank him for his
willingness to move forward in that
approach so I would Advocate that if the
committee can find uh confident in this
that uh I think it would be prudent if
the bill would have moved forward
but I asked for a sense of the committee
this will not be a vote but it just so I
need a kind of a general consensus
that we asked
representative Pearl to come back to
improve his
amendment of
uh
you know 15 579 h
and add the statutory cap
and add
and remove the federal projects
anything else
uh
I think I'm getting a sense grassy's up
uh not only is not cool is that hard was
that
Cohen is down and has his hand raised
you have
an issue that
oh my issue is I would like to wait and
get a financial impact statement if
possible I'm not objecting to miss
representative moffatt's suggestions I
just would be more comfortable waiting
and getting the financial impact with
the changes so he doesn't have to go
crazy doing it today
and then I ask the same question
well here's what will have to happen if
we do that
we will have to have another meeting
later on and this would be the only bill
so everybody will have to show up
uh a week from today
because that's and it may not even be
available then so
uh
is the only other choice would be that
we would post that we would retain the
bill and it would not would not become
law until after the first of the uh
after the first of the year
uh
[Music]
representative grassy followed by
representative harp yes Mr chairman I
think that if we do pass this uh
certainly with the concern that we want
to see a fiscal analysis done fiscal
impact of this build that let's go to
the Senate and they can get that
information and deal with it there as
far as the budget's concerned that is
that is very true thank you very much
representative
uh representative representative
uh thank you Mr chairman perhaps uh
having uh the representative go for the
amendment maybe during the break
um Mr Pelletier can go find out how many
uh because he might have a record of how
much money went over that cap on even
last year's uh applications uh who
should be maybe he might be able to just
tell us that and come back this
afternoon and give us that number
actually almost like representative
Valentina been here longer than most of
us uh
the uh did you hear a representative
Harps uh
uh I I did I did hear that like I said
last year the fees were fifty thousand
dollars I mean we can do the the simple
math uh to figure that out the dot one
was the Big E which was 22 000 that
would be gone from 22 to 37.50 if this
were implemented uh I also want to
caution that I think when you look at
the exemptions they're based on funding
source and I do have concern and I can
check further into this but I do have
concern that if we strike the federal
projects out of Representative Pearl's
Amendment
that that may uh impact dot because many
of their projects are federally funded
so I would have a that would concern me
right off the bat
um I don't think it's going to be a big
fiscal impact if we leave the federal
pod in that Amendment but I caution the
committee that this exemption is based
on funding in a lodge or the Lion's
Share projects and Dot are federally
funded so that would be a concern for me
on its first blush
yeah having been a city councilman at a
local level I know that you don't ever
really have the federal government
coming in and doing projects unless it's
an Army Core thing for uh you know
flooding purposes or emergency purposes
but he's right all of most of our
projects are federally funded when we do
a lot of these big projects so that it
may be that it's an unintended
consequence but the local community pays
a portion of those funds and if we have
to pay those fees it's going to have a
major impact on the local community so
it's probably not something it certainly
wasn't something we were considering but
I would agree I don't think we should
exempt the federal projects
so
you have a question from the two panels
okay who we have
attendee Kevin Nyon uh he's from the
three he's from the Department of
Transportation
uh you know uh Mr Nyan uh could you come
up would you uh
come forward
standby
why don't you your floor is yours good
morning thank you uh for the record
Kevin Nyan I manage the environmental
office here at the D.O.T
um if if it's okay with the chair uh
turning on my video would take uh moving
around some computers nope that's fine
okay great thank you
thank you very much I I um I just want
to Echo or actually
appreciate uh the comments offered by Mr
Pelletier from Des that um certainly
exempting Federal projects would have an
effect on the department
um or or not exempting the federal
projects
um into Mr pelletier's point a project
that he was referring to which was the
twenty thousand dollar plus project
um was in fact a federal aid project so
uh so I guess I I guess I that would be
my my comments is to express you know
appreciation for that sentiment
um and be prior to
um the sun setting of the statute it is
true that we did not pay uh permitting
fees for Shoreline permits
um and uh any amendment that would cap
that at the 37.50 would would be
appreciated so uh that's all I just
wanted to say thank you and I'm happy to
answer any questions that you might have
yeah just just if I could speak quickly
I should have said this earlier uh to my
knowledge and as you know representative
this is year 49 for me the yes so I go
back a long way but to my knowledge
there's been only one actual Federal
application since the Inception of the
Shoreland program all of the other
source fundings were mostly with DOT so
I want to reiterate I I think it would
be prudent to leave that in
representative Pearl's Amendment
thank you
so so really uh what we are talking
about for an amendment to the amendment
would be a statutory cap of 37.50
anybody agree to that
any issue any issues that uh
everybody uh so we could send
Representatives
I'm sorry representative Smith and pearl
both have their handsome all right
representative uh Smith's first
okay thank you Mr yeah thank you Mr
chair um all of a sudden I feel like
I've lost my my my knowledge here
if we are exempting
projects funded by Municipal County
state or federal entities
they're exempt from the fees so what's
the statutory cap going to do
and that's probably a question for Mr
Pelletier
if they're not paying a fee why is there
a cap honestly unless it's two different
things completely
yeah
Mr proletari can you help us with that
what are whereabouts does the statutory
cap go just caps on top of every
on every Faith he's muted
yeah here I am uh they're exempt from
the fee and I guess we'd have to think
about wordsmithing that but the intent
was that they would still apply for an
application but the fee would be capped
at 3 750 dollars
so I'm sure I trust representative Pearl
talking with OLS can figure out the
appropriate language that uh perhaps
exemption isn't the word that should be
in the sentence but the intent here I
think that I'm advocating for is that
they would submit an application but the
fee would be capped at 37.50
thank you Mr chair all right actually
that was pretty much the question I was
going to ask is so the cap is actually
capping them not to exceed 37.50 I just
want to make sure I understood and we
are leaving the feds in still correct
thank you
um
[Music]
your question answered
I'm sorry I froze for just a second my
apologies I turned my video back I've
tried again all right you're uh you're
you're you understand what's being asked
so we want to cap we want to uh cap that
so that
statutorily they can their fees will not
exceed 37.50 and we're leaving the
federals in the exemption is that
correct yes
okay thank you
I will take that to OLS and get it done
wait a minute don't leave yet all right
all right representative Smith this is
yeah this is a follow-up to that so if
we are capping the fee that could be
paid
then it's not an exemption
you know it would be permits uh shell
costs of permits shall be
um capped at 37.50 not exempt from
permitting fees because they wouldn't be
exempt they would just get much reduced
rates
is that correct that I think that's what
we're talking about
is that question for me I'm sorry I
wasn't clear it's probably this is
representative Pearl yeah it's a
question for anybody well it's actually
a question probably forever too
here I am again okay the uh the question
is is it is not is it it is not an
exemption it's a capping of the of the
feed they pay up that they pay
37.50 uh but no more than them yes I
think representative Pearl hit the nail
right on the head the word exemption has
to go away but the the wordsmithing of
the applications for those four entities
would be capped at 37.50 I think
representative Smith and I'm sure Judith
was going to say the same thing so
cap makes sense
foreign
yes I I think if you just say this still
caps the fees at 37 uh 50 for municipal
County state and federal projects from
permitting I think that fixes it
all right uh representative Spain thank
you
one day on the head so I've got to get
you and
what is going to be happening with our
desire to take out the non-profit
organizations
is that going to also be taken out of
this appears
the amendment replaces the non-profit
organizations okay so that will remain
that we're taking that out and then
we're adding the cap and then Bob's your
uncle
so there are no further questions no
further questions are we are we ready
then for to send uh representative Pearl
out to make the required changes and the
representative Burrell no exchanges
you're going to have to make
thank you Mr chair I believe I do okay
as we're glad one of us is if you have
thumbs up from grashing and published in
Oregon all right just just one one quick
thing yes just for clarification costs
of permit these shall be capped at 37.50
per permit or per applicant
uh I think the permit corrector
correct Mr Pelletier it's poor permit
correct prayer application the
application fee would be capped at 37.50
big application
all right
representative Pearl your uh
I think you can uh be off and make your
phone call and see what Jerry you can do
hopefully something gets back to us by
uh at least like two o'clock at least
all right thank you that was going to be
my next question what your timing was so
I will reach out to OLS and see if I can
yeah thank you yeah we're gonna continue
our uh exacting uh after uh two o'clock
okay I'll make sure to try and make sure
they have that thank you
two o'clock would be the
drop dead we should be still in an
executive
all right
uh it's
uh it gets time that we
uh I'm gonna end this uh executive
session we'll pick the we'll pick it up
executive session uh uh after we
uh we're gonna have at one o'clock we're
hearing 4 46 and 2 o'clock we're into
executive session and this will be the
first part of uh it'll be picked up
after two o'clock so
in the meeting I'll adjourn and
Mr chair yes do we have other people
wishing to speak on this bill
uh you're right we do
actually
uh the only youngest person to wish to
speak was uh uh darling forced Jason
Randall with his hands up in the
audience oh okay
oh first I'll recognize darling force
that she wishes to speak
is she there she's there standby
and now I want to see if she disagrees
with her boss
all right she's ready how about how
about now
okay yep
uh sorry for some reason as soon as you
uh as soon as you tried to unmute me it
booted me out and said rejoining so it
may be something about how you're
unmuting people
that said uh this is Darlene Force
Shoreline section supervisor with the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services
and I really didn't want to speak I was
told to be here as technical expertise
just in case anybody had questions so I
don't need to say anything else sounds
like you guys are all over it well
there's the this was our our list says
testifying two minutes oh no I just was
told to make myself available so if you
had questions I would have answered them
Jason Randall Jason Randall are you
there uh were you not on the on our list
but go right ahead uh will you identify
yourself who you represent town that
you're in
where you live and
uh
and then the floor will be yours and
make it
well good morning can you hear me uh yep
and committee members my name is Jason
Randall I am the superintendent at
Plymouth Village Water and Sewer
District in Plymouth New Hampshire I'm
speaking today in favor of the bill uh
397 on the shoreline protection
exemption for municipalities Village
districts and precincts
a little bit of background
um
the district started planning and
financing a sewer Force main replacement
project in 2017 and 2018
at the time
RSA 483 B5 B
3 Exempted public utility lines from the
shoreline permitting fees
until at Sunset it like it was
recognized earlier
um this reversal created a surprise
impact fee on this project for the
District of approximately 30 to 35
thousand dollars
uh that that this this was
um in 2020 so I know that's one of the
projects that wasn't brought up earlier
um because we have reached out to Des to
request a waiver
the waiver
um for that project was denied twice by
Des
um
and we asked for
um the second time I believe we asked
for the project to be considered a
permit by notification project which
would have included a 400 fee and that
was also denied
uh we did
um uh have reach out to Executive
counselor cryons and he interceded on
the district's behalf uh to help get a
waiver for the project uh so ultimately
uh Des had approved a waiver uh for the
the permit so that 35 000 fee went to a
400 fee for the district
um the project
um
the Des considered the project a new
utility due to a change in the alignment
of the existing Force main and temporary
disturbances abutting
um the baker River
the district believed that the
construction work was an important
Improvement to an existing utility and
the alignment needs needed to change to
allow for maintenance of the Force main
following Construction
uh so I think this is kind of the uh
difference that I don't believe was
brought up
um in regard to a new project versus an
existing utility uh that would would
allow a municipality to apply for a
permit by notification and essentially
be exempt of the impact fees that would
come with a new project
um uh new project permit
so
the uh you know moving forward if the
amendment is not passed for an exemption
the district will also face significant
Shoreland permit fees in the next few
years ranging between 15 and 25 thousand
dollars for several Water and Sewer
infrastructure projects
that are federally funded through the
USDA Rural Development the state
drinking water and clean water srf funds
as well as the drinking water and
groundwater trust fund so these fees
will essentially be paid back to the
state using funds from the state and and
the federal government
small utility operations like ours
struggle with maintaining affordability
in the face of increasing requirements
and the huge cost of maintaining and
upgrading aging infrastructure
the state imposed fees only add to the
seemingly insurmountable Financial
challenges of providing the potable
water and treatment of Wastewater that
is essential to public health and safety
in every New Hampshire community
thank you for your time and
consideration in passing the house bill
397.
any any questions
um Mr Randall
or Mr Randall
I'm sure you have no further
requests all right thank you very much
uh is Nova and there are no further
requests
question okay then uh
I will
we'll pick up the hearing
uh
after 2 p.m after 2 P.M
I'll tell us and I will recess now
until one until one uh until one o'clock
and we're going on mute
okay
thank you
hmm
foreign
[Music]
we're going to open the hearing for
House Bill 446
and the chair recognizes representative
renzullo the bills French sponsor
thank you Mr chair
last session uh this committee struggled
with the impacts of off Highway
recreational vehicles
on residents living where these vehicles
are used
it is understood that these vehicles are
part of an economic Revival in some
parts of the state
they are here to stay
where is the line between their youth
and their impact on those Limited in the
area
in the course of the commute of the
committee's investigations we saw some
things that concerned us
one thing that concerned this
representative was that the use of large
off-road recreational vehicles where he
reobserved on a class six Road
with an elite with the ellipse tacit
approval of local authorities
since the people in a class six road now
have to pay for the road upkeep
should there be some protection
or restitution for damage to the role of
these vehicles that's a good question
but there's no good answer
as the transportation committee was
forming a commission to study the road
usage of non-traditional motor vehicles
and that roads including class six roads
came under their jurisdiction
to a resource recreational development
reps were added to the commission
along with the charge that the
commission shall study the on-road usage
of non-traditional Motor Vehicles
such that all terrain vehicles and such
as alterated vehicles and golf carts
unfortunately the commission has only
met twice and appears to have fallen
victim to the coven
while I still have hopes for the
commission I wanted to hedge my bet this
bill proposes a bipartisan legislative
committee
propose of members from the three
committees that should have a say on
this issue
Transportation knows roads
Municipal accounting no zoning and land
uses and resources those ohrbs
we might then be able to view all
aspects allowing recreational use
of view all the aspects of the allowing
of recreational uses on public roads
the present Commission
is still in place
and I hope we'll be up to running up and
running soon
as such I would ask that the committee
to please hold this bill in advance by
retaining it
should the present commission falter or
40 or fall short
we will have a leader a vehicle to
further address this issues and
I think that's all
are there any questions from the
committee members for representative
I see no questions okay seeing none
we'll move to the next speaker
achievements
Jason stock
associations yeah
it's coming on okay
chair represent uh
the chair recognizes Jason's stock
to speech I showed here in support of
hb446
good afternoon can you hear me yes okay
wonderful well thank you
um for the record this is Jason stock
and the executive director of the New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
and I'm I'm pleased to
want to testify in support of this I do
understand the circumstances around the
sponsor's request to retain it but I
just wanted to take this opportunity
um to raise two two points
um on the whole concept of ohrv use on
on public roads class five and class six
um I hear regularly from my members kind
of two overlying concerns and I just
wanted to get this in the record and as
this uh should this committee move
forward
um hope these would be considerations
that they would would look at one is you
know the use of these roads for by by
the landowners of the properties
adjacent to those roads you know they
are use of them for actually work
um and landowners using ohrvs to travel
on these roads
um our hope would be that you know that
there would not be anything that would
you know come out of this process that
would restrict or curtail that type of
activity
ohrvs are incredibly useful tools
for Forest management they enable
landowners to in land managers to access
back parts of their property with with
the necessary tools and instruments they
need
and uh we would hate to see that you
know curtailed
um the second is on the other hand
um ohrv use you know a lot I've been
following this subject in in your
committee for the last several years you
hear a lot about the impacts on
neighbors noise dust Etc
but the other impact is in the sponsor
had mentioned it damaged to the roads um
as landowners will will go into uh we'll
have to use a class six road to access a
property to go in and harvest timber
because the town is not obligated to in
you know invest in it the landowners
that are conducting the timber sale are
investing it and it gets it can become
very frustrating
um to see that investment literally
washed away due to rutting and
inappropriate inappropriate use so I
just wanted to raise these two points I
look forward to the commission
um that that that is currently on hold
looking forward to getting that seeing
that up and operational but I appreciate
your time this afternoon and I just
wanted to get these two thoughts or
concepts out there and look forward to
working with with you on this in the
future thank you
thank you Mr Stark for your testimony
are there any questions for for Mr stock
by the committee members
no question okay seeing nine we'll move
to the next speaker thank you
recognizes Stephen wilty
to talk in opposition to hb446
okay
Mr Welty could you please state your
name who you represent
position on the bill
can you hear me
yes yes my name is Stephen Wilkie I'm
the operations manager for New Hampshire
off Highway Vehicle Association
hello yeah you're coming in really faint
all right
[Music]
um
hello hello yeah I hate to tell you to
yell at your computer but I think you
may have to hello can you hear me now
that's much better okay all right
um my name is Stephen Wilkie I'm the
operations manager for New Hampshire off
Highway Vehicle Association
we represent all the ohrv enthusiasts in
New Hampshire and we're made up of 28
member clubs and 14 000 members strong
um
HB 1182 the study commission uh Nova has
a seat on that commission and as a
sponsor stated uh was off to a slow
start because of covid
um but I have uh faked that once that
gets moving
um information about this will start
flowing and uh some some good ideas will
come out of that
um in 2019
this legislature passed a bill uh to
require two-week notice by verified mail
to all a Butters uh for these class five
and class six roads uh and and have a
public hearing
um since that legislature there there
have been towns like Stewartstown North
Stratford Warner Hinsdale and Monroe New
Hampshire who have all closed down some
or all of their roads to ohrvs
um for you know mainly the reasons of of
neighbors complaining
um in Gorham uh the state has worked
diligently to put in a new parking area
uh up on route 16.
and now Gorham has has requested to
close the Route 2 parking area which was
a major point in contention a few years
ago and actually spurred some
legislation
um which which failed
um and and it seems like that parking
area may go back to the hikers who want
to access the presidential Trail and
other hiking trails around with the new
parking area up on route 16.
some of the clubs have already put in
new trails in the woods and and rerouted
uh their Trails off from class five and
some of the class roads in the hot spots
as far as maintaining the class six and
class 5 roads under the grant and aid
program that is offered through Bureau
of trails a local municipality can apply
for these Grant need
requests they can spend money on their
class five roads that they've opened up
and there's towns like Pittsburgh who
the the club has put calcium chloride on
some of the dirt roads to keep down the
dust
but municipalities often don't know this
is a source of income that they could
use to offset the cost of taking care of
these roads if they open them to ohrvs
as far as the class six roads they can't
put money towards and so if a club
gets permission to use that class six
Road as a trail now the club is eligible
for grant and aid through the same Grant
made program
to work on those roads the local club
I'm involved with just put over ten
thousand dollars worth of work in a
short section of class six roads between
Cornish and Newport
um which has has not seen any work over
the years and really needed some some
basic attention
um this was all spurred through a
Cooperative program with the City of
Claremont to protect the Watershed which
we do have a couple of trails going
through
um as far as Nova on the New Hampshire
off highway vehicle association has an
association they have created a trail
Patrol program to encourage clubs uh
which there are some clubs that already
had Trail Patrols
but we're encouraging Trail Patrols in
all clubs to get to these hot spots and
try to educate the Riders on on what it
takes to maintain these Trails on the
roads and on private property
um
it's it's no secret that the economic
factor is there but really the impact to
everyone is really what is of most
concern and
um Nova has worked on an education
program also
for those Trail Patrol people to hand
out rack cards and encourage them to
join clubs
currently we only have about a 40
percent
um uh percentage who join clubs versus
don't join clubs most people who join
the clubs are respectful of the trails
they understand what the clubs go
through to put the trails out there
the the people who don't join the clubs
and just pay the extra thirty dollars
there's so many new riders that they
just don't understand in the in the last
four or five years of growth you know
have shown that so all this
um legislation over the last few years
has really spurred
um a lot of positivity coming out of
this
in working with uh the the neighbors and
the butters that are uh unhappy
um grant and aid increased uh in 2018
due to the club membership program and
it used to be only about 330 thousand
dollars went to the clubs to maintain
trails and last year they were awarded
close to 700 000 which
created almost a million dollars worth
of Trail work last year
last year so um the notion of thinking
that these class six roads are getting
no attention uh can't be the furthest
from the truth and the the work is
actually being done as this money keeps
coming in and as our registration
numbers grow that Grant need
a pool grows and more money goes to the
trails supporting this
um sport that so many people enjoy
and that concludes the testimony
um you know this this should illustrate
that the current system is working and
most municipalities are addressing the
complaints and concerns of their
residents
okay thank you Mr Wilkie are there any
questions from the members of the
committee for Mr wookie
that's an answer uh representative Smith
representative Smith for a question
please
thank you
can't hear you yeah thank you Mr chair
and um thank you Mr Wilkie for taking my
question
um you talk about the grant program and
which I have heard of before
foreign
visiting a few sites last year
um
it did not seem that the people who
lived on the classics roads or owned the
property under the classics Road were
aware of this how does one apply for one
of these grants and what is the process
so the municipality themselves would
need to apply for that they would want
to contact uh the bureau trails in
Concord
um Lisa meffer is the one who's in
charge of the grant Aid System there's
currently a search out for new chief of
Bureau Trails who is who I would
normally uh direct you to the acting
um Chief is Clint Savage
um and that's all under Sarah Stewart
who has done a wonderful job working
with all of the clubs in Nova through
the loss of the chief
thank you those those rules are also
found on the bureau Trails website
um and it's they're the 8400 res 8400
rules and I will be submitting uh
testimony on
no written testimony on Nova's behalf
along with supporting documentation uh
which should be coming your way today
thank you you're welcome
any other questions for uh Mr Wilkie
seeing that we'll move to the next
speaker
recognizes William Collins to speak on
House Bill 446.
Chris Collins if you could please just
identify yourself please represent and
how much time you'll be taking
it
you can unmute yourself please Mr
promise
hello
there you go near you
okay my name is William Collins and I
live in uh on North Road in Hillsboro on
a Class 5 Road
okay
I worked with uh
the committee a couple of years ago
relative to toxic chemicals on the rail
trails
anyway uh
what I have to say today is that the
committee is our only voice
uh against in against our protection
against the ohrv lobby which is very
powerful
and the only way we can get any redress
on this and and protect our
constitutional rights and the Fifth
Amendment uh and and to avoid inverse
condemnation
is to have a committee that's going to
come up with some regulations that's
rsas that's going to protect us from uh
the increasing
encroachment on our property on our
roads
and uh
you know
protect us from the stress related to
noise fumes and dust
and uh
they're specifically designed aohr Visa
specifically designed for trails and
really not designed for on roads class 5
or class six because it results in
erosion and other issues
um
the loss of peace and quiet due to ohrv
noise is well documented and the the
noise results in stress and the fumes
are unhelpful
as the previous speaker mentioned the uh
the uh
increase in registrations is is growing
every year and so the desire for
operating in other areas by The
Operators grows every year because they
there's just so many trails for them to
ride on the state has spent thousands
and thousands of dollars for Mo for the
Jericho State Park area where they can
ride and that connects with numerous
other Trails throughout the Northeast
Northern political state
the southern part of the state is a much
more densely populated even though I
live on a a class six or class five road
with only four immediate neighbors
um we all relish our peace and quiet and
we cannot put a price on that
um three years ago a local Club attended
attempted to get permission to operate
ATVs in Hillsboro we formed a local
committee we hired an attorney and we
prepared to
um proceed if the Selectmen had desired
had
um determined that they were going to
allow that club to operate we presented
arguments and the Selectmen decided not
to allow the club to operate because of
all the opposition we've had numerous
hearings in Hillsboro and and are not
hearings but but meetings with the
Selectmen over ATV issues in town and
it's I'd say it's 99 negative because of
the residents being upset by operators
racing up and down roads and the noise
in general is is really distasteful
and and disruptive
I'm not sure how many people are aware
of the uh the incident that happened in
in Gorham a few years ago when they
retired or orthopedic surgeon from South
Dakota built his uh dream retirement
home and then a couple of years later
they opened up an adjacent Trail and a
parking area near his house and he
opposed it and they found out and they
proceeded to harass him to the point
where a year later he took his own life
and as a result of the ohrv operation
immediately around its property and
harassment by operators
so um that's the kind of stress that
they can induce and um we're I'm really
in support of this bill that the
committee will come up with some kind of
rational
um regulations and rsas to prevent
um
the encroachment on our rights of and uh
the um the lobbying efforts of the ohrv
is is you know we need we need support
by our representatives to to um protect
us from that Lobby which is very
powerful and and
um
successful so a lot of the as I
understand it a lot of the bills are
regulations that were proposed years ago
have were repeatedly watered down over
the last 10 years or so to the point
where they were no longer affect it
um and most of the and as the um
previous is Mr Wilkie stated there's a
lot of unhappy residents out there and
resulted in regulations so
um and because people have basically Fed
Up and the towns are closing Trails
because of numerous complaints because
people just can't they don't want to
deal with the noise and fumes and dust
so basically I see them as they're kind
of like smokers they um they really
enjoy what they're doing with very
little regard for the secondary effects
of
um you know which was Once Upon a Time
second-hand smoke but now it's it's
we're dealing with people that are are
generating fumes dust and noise and they
really don't have any regard for the
people that that uh live on the roads
where they go by
and so hopefully the committee will be
formed and and it will come up with
something constructive to protect
residents and and to support our rights
under the Constitution
and that that concludes my testimony
thank you very much Mr Collins I
appreciate it sir uh are there any
questions
from the committee for for Mr Collins
representative
yeah Mr Collins I appreciate you coming
on today and I remember
uh talking to you about this in detail
last summer it might be helpful if you
could describe your front yard and the
amount of traffic that goes in front of
your front yard on a on a daily basis
especially on on a weekend
um on the weekends it's it the uh normal
Vehicles regular vehicle traffic
increases dramatically on the weekends
uh fortunately
um we through reports to the police
complaints or the police they have been
uh very helpful in keeping the ATVs down
but uh four years ago the Selectmen
decided without con without talking to
anyone else Consulting anyone that they
would allow 08 the utvs to operate in
all the town roads class five roads in
any any road under 30 miles an hour
posted for under 30. so
um the traffic has been
intermittent
um but uh it can be it can be annoying
when when a seven or eight Vehicles go
by all at once
I would say on the weekends we might
have 10 or 15 a day go by this is this
is ohrvs in my neighborhood
but um on a regular basis it is at one
once once it's the Summer's over it it
Windows off to almost down to almost
nothing
but um right now we've kept them at Bay
because of the of um uh our activities
as a committee but um we want to keep it
that way we want to keep it from from
spreading we want them to be
um
kept on Trails where they where they're
designed to be right now the Selectmen
are working on a bill around a bill but
a uh a rule for town a town an ordinance
to uh limit ohrvs and their activities
uh I'm not privy to exactly where it is
at this point but they're waiting to to
have a hearing in June when uh rep
um residents that no longer that are not
here in the winter time will return
because there's summer homes and so that
they'll have input
so it's become an issue and and um
the the Selectmen are trying to address
it
so as far as many as car vehicles going
by my house
um in the summer there's probably a
couple dozen a day and um but but the
weekdays it's not it's much lighter
is there any other
Mr Collins
we'll move to the next speaker
yep
Joe recognizes Caleb Dobbins
to become a bill
you can just identify yourself who you
represent and how much time you'll
you'll need yeah thank you Mr chairman
uh for the record my name is Caleb
Dobbins I'm a resident of the town of
hanaker I'm speaking as a landowner
um uh in the town of Henniker and a
private citizen of New Hampshire
um hopefully I can wrap this up within
five minutes uh I'd just like to comment
um I understand you folks are discussing
class five and class six roads I'm going
to probably limit all of my testimony
specifically to class six roadways they
are very different than a class five
roadway I will note a few things
um the gentleman from Nova noted that
legislation has changed many things in
the ohrv industry
um all the more reason for you folks to
have a committee and continue to look at
this subject there is effects that are
being happening and the only reason
these changes are happening is because
the legislature is in fact actually
looking at these things so I applaud the
legislature for willing to take these
issues on
so just quickly on class six roads class
six roads were originally designed
simply to give folks who previously had
access to properties in 1925 the state
decided what roads needed to stay truly
public roads and which ones needed to be
remain open such that people who lived
on that property could access the
property so that was 1925. it talks
about being adverse the public use must
have been adverse which means that the
public
has to have either claimed or believed
they had a right to access that property
okay oh hrvs were not created and were
not in existence in New Hampshire until
1968. so clearly ohrv users do not have
an adverse right to access the
properties that they do not own
um so the fact that towns have to give
special permission to use these roadways
for ohrvs and it's really class five or
six clearly the use of ohrvs is an
unanticipated use of these roadways due
to the need for a special permission
um I will speak quickly on the
maintenance and the liability relative
to class six roadways so right now
legislation allows a town to open up a
Class 6 roadway for ohrv use but as
other folks have stated the butters are
the ones that must maintain that
um it had been it had been noted that
there was a grant and aid program
that towns can access and somehow that
money goes to the clubs I'm not a lawyer
but I would argue that would make the
club as an agent of the town because the
town is the one who's granting the
permission for the club to maintain that
roadway not the landowner the landowner
has no say
in whether or not a Classics roadway
that runs through their property and
they own that property they have no say
they cannot say yes or no they are only
notified
um so I would argue that any funds any
public funds and that is what Grant Aid
is it is state and federal funds that
are expended on a class six roadway
could very well and should revert that
road to a class 5 roadway because public
funds have been spent on that roadway
which will then change the
classification from a class six to a
class five
private landowners are taxed on this
property
okay they can't even do things on this
that they would be able to do if it was
a class 5 roadway many many
um mortgage companies won't even give
you a mortgage if you want to build a a
a house on a class six roadway because
it's not a class five roadway it's a
class six roadway it doesn't have the
same maintenance that that is required
of a class five because the town
holds absolutely no liability or
responsibility to maintain that in any
way shape or form and in effect they do
maintain it it becomes a class 5 roadway
ohrb statutes require a landowner's
permission to use property in this case
the property is the is the class six
landowners property the town that only
has a only has a basically an easement
through there that was granted in 1925.
um so in in fact ohrv folks should
probably have to get permission from
that landowner
um I applaud again the commission the uh
this committee for um looking to form a
study committee on this
um I would suggest possibly a commission
but I understand that gets unwieldy so I
won't
um and I'll just simply say that that
thank you for allowing the landowners on
Classics roadways the possibility to
Take Back Control of their property
rights and if the towns feel strongly
enough that ohrvs need to be on that
roadway then they should seriously
consider making it a class five roadway
take over the maintenance responsibility
and allow those landowners to be able to
develop that property
that they cannot do now on a class six
roadway
thank you
thank you Mr Gardens
is there any questions from the
committee for Mr daughters
recognize representative Smith for a
question
look we can't hear you
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Dobbins you don't by chance have your
testimony written down to you because I
was madly writing everything you said
and I missed most of it
I I could certainly uh forward the notes
that I have that I was right that I was
speaking over um and I will forward it
to the committee as it explains in the
legislature
um guides that are online
great thank you so much
any other questions from the committee
for Mr
thank you register Dobbins I was very
informative appreciate it
[Music]
he's coming
recognizes Monique petrovsky to speak on
the bill
you can just State your your name uh we
represent and how much time you need
to speak that would be wonderful
hello
hi this is Monique petrovsky I'm not
sure if I heard my name called or not
yep
okay thank you sorry about that
um so thank you for the opportunity to
speak in support of House Bill 446 and
um I did send in my uh notes to the
email that I was given
um so I'm Monique petrovsky and I'm from
Stewartstown New Hampshire
and I returned to this area after
retiring from the U.S Public Health
Service as a captain after 29 years of
service and I include this information
because I worked for the Centers for
Disease Control in the National
Institute of Health
in my career and so I believe this
pertinent to my testimony on concern for
the unhealthy effects of Malawi ohrvs on
class five and six roads
um as as Mr Collins
mentioned the quality of life is uh
greatly adversely affected the noise
decibels created by ohrbs exceed The Who
standard quality of life in fact they
exceed the decibels found in snowmobiles
the year-round permanent homeowners
quality of life has been greatly
diminished throughout the ride the Wilds
um
Trail
the other concern is the dust or a
particulate matter which is called
pm10id PM 2.5 which alludes to the size
of the Dust but that the dust created by
these roads has known negative health
effects the state of Alaska Department
of Environmental Conservation has done
extensive studies on that and although
um
extensive studies haven't been done in
New Hampshire I would say that that's
like saying we should do studies to see
if smoking adversely affects us in New
Hampshire we know that it is about
having PM particles 10 and 2.5 are bad
they penetrate deep into the respiratory
tract nuisance staffs also degrades the
quality of life because it settles and
evades all living spaces including
window cells inside the homes
that's how that's how invasive the dust
is and of course porches and barbecues
are out of the question
I'm also concerned about the
environmental effects of our roads I
grew up in Northern New Hampshire
Northern Vermont
um so I've known the roads for over 60
years
and oh HIV is due to the Nabi tires are
eroding the roads down to the ledge
contributing to erosion extreme widening
of the roads and when it rains it
creates huge puddles that the Ohr
recenter and enjoy where they use the
opportunity to mud in the puddles on the
roads which means they they'll go
through as fast as they can so they get
splashed with the with the mud
which further exacerbates the erosion
problem
the recommendation that from the studies
from other states have been done
in response to the dust and the noise
and the erosion
is rerouting traffic away from homes off
these roads and truly not
not allowing them on roads where people
live on
the other the third concern that I'd
like to just talk about briefly is due
to the erosion roads that were once seen
that can considered calendar photo
worthy have been as I mentioned reduced
to ledge
but they've now become impassable by car
I'm I'm I'm official fisherman and I
used to fish all of these streams I
can't even reach them by car anymore and
even if I could reach them by car the
dust and the noise from the yellow hivs
would make it such an unpleasant
experience that I wouldn't want to but
I'm also concerned about the erosion and
sometimes
um in judicious use of salt on the roads
near the Brooks that that they're using
um I I did submit pictures at earlier
hearings of how they're salting the
roads and they it looked like snowfall
and snowballs and they were mere feet
from Brooks
the third thing that I'm concerned about
um and I I applaud the committee's
um they I applied The Honorable chairman
renzulu to to and look into this more
clearly is
um even the coloss trail
um which is now a hiking trail which is
162 miles that goes through co-auth has
had problems on social media hikers talk
about
um the unpleasantness of how hiking this
Trail a very historic trail that
actually began in 1803 following the
Abenaki Trails
um and that they're in the process of
rerouting off of the class five and six
roads because of
um
how well when they have been harassed as
well
um so I I feel What's Happening by have
allowing ohrvs on class five and six
roads is not only the quality of life
the environmental effects the health
effects
um but I think with self-selecting uh
for a sport that's driving other people
away which I find very concerning and I
did look at some of the statistics
and for 2019 there was 159
000 hunting registrations
uh I'm sorry
for fishing there was 159 000
registrations for hunting there was over
57 000 and registrations for ohrvs with
31 000. so to me it hits me as a
disproportionate
um of people being
um inconvenienced for a sport that
actually we have much smaller numbers
for
um thank you for the opportunity to
speak out and support up what I consider
a very important Bell
thank you very much Miss Petroski
appreciate your testimony is there any
questions
a committee
no questions see none
thank you
okay
is there anybody else
anything else in the audience that would
like to speak
on House Bill 446.
so you know we'll close the hearing on
houseboat 446.
it's going to take a five minute break
here
we are
foreign
okay good okay
welcome back everybody
open up the executive session for house
bill 446.
we're looking up for any discussion
to start
discussion or any questions or comments
on House Bill 446
representative Smith
yes Mr chair
um are we making a motion first are we
going to just discuss things first uh
we can make a motion
yeah we can make a motion if somebody
would like to make a motion on the bill
Mr chairman
yes representative
yes I'll make a motion that we retain
this bill
and representative motion
well I listened to the prime sponsor and
I think there's a lot of issues that do
need to be done uh to review uh these
class five class six and the effects on
the road so I'm in favor of the
committee but I understand why the
request to retain was made so I'll
support that request
okay do we have a second on the position
to retain
second
representative Todd seconds get my
thanks
God Mr chairperson am I allowed to ask
the sponsor a question at this point
yeah yes yes representative Cohen answer
your question uh representative or chair
however I address chairperson or a zoo
because he's not mature at this moment
so representative renzullo based on what
we've heard
uh for Testimony
would you recommend retain or ought to
pass for this bill at this point
uh either one would do uh the reason I
said retain is because it's under our
control
uh if
if you pass it
it ceases to be in our control
okay thank you yes so just follow on
yes yes
thank you I can support
um the
um representative Hearts motion at this
point no problem with it
Smith
representative Smith
yes thank you Mr chair
um in listening to the testimony
it reminded me again of just how
important initiative this is to a lot of
different people and how it's a
long-standing uh issue and I'm I will
support retain and I really hope that we
as a committee can take the time to do
the study ourselves I think we'd do a
better job than any appointed committee
and I'm really concerned that that
commission that is in shape in in that
has already been formed uh spearheaded
by the transportation committee
because they have not even started to
meet and their deadline is November and
this is one of many many issues that
they could choose to deal with I think
that we will do a better job of it even
if they do say they'll handle it
thank you representative Smith
so I I feel strongly also representative
Smith those are very good point and I
think yes the committee this has been a
hot issue for us for the last several
years and I think that I think that
suggestion is is well taken I think the
committee itself
obviously several individuals on the
committee are very familiar with the
subject matter and I think we think it's
a good job of that at least you know
getting the ball rolling on this
particular subject matter
any other questions from the committee
I guess I do have one and you
representative Smith I agree with your
your assessment so I just
procedurally the motion on the table is
to retain
if retain it then nothing happens
every
passion then it goes through and then
the committee is initiated
is that am I missing something
you can work on the bill
retained by definition you work on the
bill but not the committee
does the bill establishes a committee so
the committee isn't reformed until the
bill passes
I will I'll refer to the crime so much
uh the committee
uh with
this committee as it can work on
whatever it wants using the bills bill
the
getting the involvement of the
transportation or
information or the municipal County
would require the passing
but it would also require if we passed
through the Senate and also the assigned
by the building so it wouldn't be
um law until probably until until
so yes
so there are ideas those are the two
that's different ways
I I just wanted to understand
the ramifications of what the book was
right
it keeps the bill in front of us
and music
you passed it it would it would be
uh
Mr chair okay
you're right absolutely true and you
have representative
thank you
um I'm thinking that the reason for
retaining is to then uh decide at the
end of the the period like in November
whether we are going to uh
representative Spang we've lost your
your audio
okay
[Music]
hold on a second
okay oh already how are we doing now we
have you now okay thanks
so the recommendation uh at the end of
the uh
the period in November after we finished
with this bill will be to either
recommend it for further legislation or
not is that correct
no no
so what would be the end game here when
we finish with uh looking at this bill
it would be a representative Spang for
an ought to pass or an Ito
at the end of the routine period
if we decide and
so if we do an ought to pass then it
goes through the whole uh cycle again in
order to set up this committee is that
correct
yes that is correct
yeah so in the meantime what will we be
doing and what will be the outcome of
the work that we will be doing
well it could be a number of things
obviously it could be moving this bill
to a not to pass
uh in our work as a committee it could
produce you know obviously we could we
could file new legislation based on
findings
which we could do anyway which we could
do anyways that is correct right okay
you can also take the bill and gun it
and put something else in its place
true
and you have posts and representative
Smith
representative post
yes uh thank you for recognizing me
um uh I'm in support of retaining it I'm
working on it as a committee
um I see
um a lot of um families in our area in
our towns surrounding towns that have
these vehicles and
um I I just want to make sure we do a
good job in researching before we start
putting on restrictions on them
representative Smith
uh thank you I was just going to uh say
what representative renzullo just said
is which we can work on it we can amend
it and then it goes to the floor in
January with our recommendation
okay thank you
is there anybody else
I'd like to uh comment representative
representative Cohen
Mr chairperson I'm sorry I just need a
little clarification let me ask my
question of you and then see if you can
answer it for me if we retain if we vote
to retain this bill
and we do successfully retain the bill
when we work on it again let's just say
in November if the other committee has
done nothing is a Class 5 and class six
bills can we after we finish while we're
working on this bill
add an amendment that may affect the use
of world class five or six bills and
then vote on that as a committee for
this amended to this bill
yes we can Representatives we can amend
this bill with whatever language we feel
is pertinent to the subject matter
extreme case if we decide that um ohvr
should be banned from class five and
class six because the work we did
looking at when we're team we could put
an amendment on this bill saying
something to that effect
that is correct representative okay I
appreciate the clarification thank you
very much and I do a little support the
retain
you have no further questions any other
questions or comments on on House Bill
okay the motion is to retain we will
call the roll okay thank you chairman um
uh
representative gunski
representative gunski votes yes
representative Gould representative
Gould yes
representative Gould yes representative
Corgan yes
Oregon yes representative harb yes
or yes representative Creighton
Creighton yes
yes representative Dodge yes
attachments yes the clerk votes yes
representative Healy yes
yes
representative Mayville
representative Mabel book yes
yes representative post
representative post votes yes
most votes yes representative Smith
yes
votes yes representative Spang
representative Spang those yes
votes yes representative grassy
representative grassy votes yes I
suppose yes representative
representative gottling votes yes
problem but yes representative Cohen
yeah
yes representative Connors
representative Connors votes yes
representative Vale
representative
Bill votes yes representative Kelly
representative Kelly votes yes
representative Moran
representative Moraine votes yes
representative
representative Betsy votes yes
that's he votes yes represent uh chair
venzuela
it's yes and that's 21 yes for promotion
passes
consent
yeah
we don't need consent now
thank you
all right uh if you want to get into now
397.
yeah yep
[Music]
representative Perler
which one which one is that
that's the name entrepreneurship there's
two of them yeah
representative Pearl are you there
I don't see him
[Music]
uh maybe we can say maybe we can discuss
them we actually can bring up uh
representative Kelly I believe yeah okay
that's had some involvement in this
yes thank you Kelly are you there yep I
am
um so uh I was trying to find the the
people kept mentioning a sunset the sun
setting of the old provision I I
couldn't find where it was ever
sunsetted in fact OLS is currently
looking into they can't they haven't
been able to find what chaptered law
repealed the section that's in question
um but I did find a version the last
version of it that appeared in law from
2017 and so all I did was send that to
representative Pearl the the like the
the last version of section three or
section three of the RSA that that
actually
um had the language
um I think that's his language I think
mine's probably down below I can pull it
up
hold on a second I've got the other one
stand by
so this was at 609 is it 609 or 607 609
I think is
that it should have
happened does not have the uh
yes 607 I think 607 was the one that I
sent that was the original that was the
language that had been removed had been
repealed in a previous bill
and it and it reads
applicants for the construction of
public roads public utility lines and
Associated structures facilities public
water access facilities and projects
solely funded by Municipal County state
or federal entities shall incur and
before the old the the way it was all
used to be written it said
uh shall be exempt from these permits so
all I did was just add the 3750 cap that
Des was saying so that's the
um
that's what it said and so shall be no
greater than 37.50
is this one
representative Kelly that you were
looking for
yeah what number is that could you go to
the actual what else amendment number
yeah
4607 until seven each this is 609 each
you want 607 each yeah okay standby
line six
so that would be
there's 607.
oh yeah that uh
yes correct yep under where it says
where the x is or where the 10 section
application for construction of public
roads public utility lines and
Associated structures facilities public
water access facilities and projects
solely funded by Municipal County state
or federal entities shall incur The Firm
anything no greater than 37.50 so the
the issue that that someone had brought
up was that the Municipal Water
districts may be classified as
non-profits which is why representative
from may have included that language
originally so there was some fear that
that by that you know not not putting
the language specifically about water
access facilities that Des would not be
able to
uh Grant those that the permits and
though that seemed to be who was mainly
reaching out to us so I just I just took
the old language from 2017 and posted it
in
with it that this was the last version I
believe representative Pearl was using a
prior version of the
of the text so that's why it's there's a
slight difference and he what I did I
didn't know who to reach out to about
that so I sent that to him he sent both
sets to the
um to OLS to have them draft the
Amendments and he said that we could we
whatever we decided was the better
version of the language to go with that
and and I believe that's why he sent us
both
thank you
any discussion on the
well
she got both of them
so any discussion on which one we prefer
representative by representative Smith
uh thank you Mr chair I thought it might
be good to ask Des if this language
looks good to them
I mean I'm not sure because this is the
first time we're seeing this language
but I mean I like the way that it it
includes more specifics but I just want
to make sure it's accurate
I think Des would be the people to ask
are there anyone from Des still here
I did see uh Mr Pelletier here
all right
can you hear me yes we can no thanks
thanks for the invite uh the only
problem I have with the the Second
Amendment we're looking at 607 h
is uh public utility lines
uh that in my mind should be taken out
that would mean that the Northern Pass
project which was as you know hundreds
of miles
uh
would be exempt
so I think the First Amendment
um
that were shown is uh would be the
correct one I think
well I take out public utility lines and
Associated structures
that would be a problem
there I've got it up now this is the uh
like the 609 one
yeah
if I might jam and uh what do utilities
aren't considered non-profits uh they
charge for uh for an activity
and they're regulated by puc if they're
non-governmental
representative Penske for a question
here I just wanted to follow up
Amendment 607 was in statute
did you so you had issues when it was in
statute prior years yes we did yeah yes
we did with the public utilities section
for sure
if these two follow-up links
and how how did you address that fee
shortfall prior to the sun setting is it
just something you just
yeah it went in and it got sunset at 19.
so that was we had worked last session
but because of the pandemic uh stuff
never went to any kind of fruition so
um it just ended up being uh
uh it went away in 2019.
yeah it says it's a follow-up question
thank you Mr chair and how long was this
legislation that we see in 607 how long
was that in place for how many years
oh that was it started in 2007 I believe
and it was uh sunsettered
uh and it was sunset in 2019 both there
were two parts to the Shoreland act one
was the fee uh sun setting which was
addressed in 19. and they never
addressed the second part of the statute
which was in fact this exemption part
thank you sir representative Smith
representative Smith for a question
I actually don't remember what I was
going to ask so you can take me off that
list
and what else
questions
no sir all right I'll just ask the basic
question of the uh
of are we ready
for a motion
we are ready for a motion now well first
of all I'm gonna have to get us back
into executive session
so uh and the
continuation continuation on
representative Smith representative
Smith I remembered thank you uh Mr chair
um
I got a call at lunch and I know there
are a couple people from the Plymouth
Village Water and Sewer District here
and
most of their work is paid for most of
their projects are paid for with a
combination of Grants and rate payer
rate rate the rates paid by rate payers
so would they be eligible for this cap
that's a question I get a question
probably of of Mr Pelletier not
yeah it would be our intent that they
would be eligible for the cap okay thank
you and if because if I might uh Mr
chair it's a solely funded by Municipal
County state or federal so if they've
got a mix of Federal loans grants and
Municipal input than they would be
capped thank you very much
point that um
don't do Village Water and Sewer for
instance is its own municipality
water districts are their own they are
actually municipality
yeah well anything below the question
really is um
uh other real things like school
districts water districts they would
also be under this
as what we could treat it as
municipalities
the physical there
oh I wasn't I didn't understand that was
uh aimed at me oh okay yeah yeah no that
would be but if you're concerned about
Clarity you could always add Village
districts they're the only real other
utility entities that we deal with but
they're considered Municipal uh they
just come under the category of Village
District in some cases
yeah
they represent I think all of them would
be yeah Kelly uh representative Kelly
for a question or for a comment I I
agree I think that uh Mr Pelletier is
correct I think that's this if they if
they if his I think we should go forward
with with the First Amendment if that's
the case
okay
all right uh can we go into executive
session now
all right I'm going to end the
testimony section and we're going to go
home to Executive session
uh house bill
and uh
looking for
I have a motion
uh well do I have a motion
representative Kelly has his hand up oh
motion to motion to adopt uh Amendment
0609h well would you uh maybe like you
could make the motion uh to pass as
amended and then well then we'll go with
the amendment and then back in
motion to pass as amended okay and
you're perfect men and we'll discuss the
amendment first and the amendment is
uh what is the amendment again
0609h the one on the screen currently
0.609
09h do I have that yes
on the any discussion on the amendment
if not
see no hands
clerk please call the roll on the
amendment
and Amendment 0.609h
thank you
um representative gunski representative
gunski votes yes he votes yes
representative Gould yes
votes yes representative Morgan yes
representative Morgan votes against
representative harp yes
our votes yes representative Creighton
yes
Creighton votes yes representative Dodge
Dodge yes
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Healy
um
yes representative Mabel
yes
it's yes representative post
representative post votes yes
post votes yes representative Smith
representative Smith votes yes
Smith folks yes representative Spang
representative Spang votes yes
Bank votes yes representative Grazie
representative grassy votes yes
representative gottling
representative
all right
representative gottling votes yes
bottling votes yes representative Cohen
votes yes
representative Connors
representative Connors votes yes
representative Vale
representative bail votes yes
there's an Avail votes yes
representative Kelly
representative Kelly yes
Kelly votes yes representative Moran
uh representative Moran votes yes
representative dude see a representative
Dusty votes yes
he votes yes and chairman Zulu uh chair
votes yes
uh
[Music]
that's that is on the amendment
I
chair I think has screwed up did I get a
uh did I get a second on uh
representative Kelly's motion I'll
second that Mr chairman representative
brassy
representative Grassley is second okay
thank you very much representative
uh okay now on the motion about to pass
as amended representative Kelly seconded
by representative grassy
uh
uh clerk anybody any more any discussion
seeing none
the clerk please call the roll
thank you chair uh representative gunski
votes yes
he votes yes representative Gould yes
yes representative Morgan yes
Morgan votes yes representative Harvard
yes
yes representative Creighton Creighton
yes representative Dodge Dodge yes
Associates the clerk votes yes
representative Healy
yes
representative
representative Mabel books yes
Naval votes yes representative post
representative host visits yes
representative Smith
representative Smith votes yes
votes yes representative Spang
representative Spang votes yes
bang votes yes representative brassy
yes
representative kotlin representative
gottling votes yes
representative Cohen
no one votes yes
I think did you say yes representative
Cohen
yes I did okay they cut off
representative Connors representative
Connors votes yes
representative Bale
representative Dale votes yes
Bill votes yes representative Kelly
representative Kelly votes yes Kelly
votes yes representative Moran
representative Moran votes yes
and representative
representative Dusty votes yes
he votes yes and chairman
uh Jared votes uh chair of Otis
that's 21 yeses
[Music]
oh yeah uh
okay representative Kelly
the maker of the motion uh you represent
are you um
uh going to be preparing the blur
I will do my best it'll be my first one
so I'll set it to to representative
Smith after and have her proofread it
okay I don't I don't mind that saves me
some work
but yeah uh the first one that it'll be
20 it's uh as a 21 to nothing uh any
issue with the consensus that they were
on consent
okay that should do it on that one now
let's go back to
we are a still an executive session and
we got the we have got to do all of the
bills it's possibly if we can
uh I'm going to do the fields
with a men with additional amendments
try to do it in the numerical order
uh these like the
take up House Bill
235 because the issue on groundwater
withdrawals
is
a an amendment
that was sent out yesterday to everyone
if they were able to get it
the I don't hear any no's so what this
amendment is
well first of all this
this bill
was
a retread
um last from last year
this was passed by this committee
that it passed unanimously
and it died of covet in the Senate
but every the bill
uh
was ex was
that was something that we all we all
agreed on as the uh as constituted as
this committee was constituted back then
uh
the
uh the
sponsor of the bill
sent
the
is he uh set in the bill he's proposed
was a little bit different when it
improved on this on his bill
well
I'm
I was I
was presented with a very
a good good idea by
representative Smith
who said you know we passed this bill
last time why not pass the same bill
this time which is a very good idea and
my ideas I I believe it to be because it
was a bill that
when everyone originally presented but
it would originally passed last time
didn't have any of the issues
that the bill
uh as presented that we've presented
before us uh has to has uh has today so
this amendment
basically recreates the bill that this
committee passed
and
I've my feeling
that
someone should never
you know never tried never lift the
gifts worse than the mouth the one you
know take what you've got and go so my
feeling is that this puts is the better
build
and it is it doesn't have to have any of
the issues that the
the new the the bill that was presented
presents to us so
we'll see this is uh
Amendment
0-580 so I would ask
representative to uh for a motion to out
the past as amended
[Music]
ought to pass as amended yeah okay
representative post has a question uh
representative post for a question
thank you very much Mr chairman does
that remove the um Crystal note I mean
is that going to alleviate the fiscal
note on that the fiscal note would not
apply to this to this bill okay thank
you
because uh if I if uh testimony
testimony shows that uh the testimony
that there was
the the bill uh because the bill of the
amendment does not
specify specifically
what the de how the Des
would uh implement this bill
and the hip and there is documentation
that the Des had no problem with the
bill the original with the bill as
amended because it would be actually be
a bill that was
passed last year with dps's acquiescence
that that should be should be the that
should take care of the fiscal itself
fiscal note would not apply
uh
any other questions
oh you have another additional questions
um I I just wanted to ask you
um you were making a motion it's kind of
procedural and I wanted to see the
difference
um with this one that we're going to
vote on the bill is ought to pass with
Amendment but on the one we just okay
the motion promotion is uh the motion
the way it started off is you started
off
ought to pass as amended then we got
have to take up
the amendment specifically
and then we've then the motion would
then be uh if we would then be ought to
pass as a meant that after we had passed
the approval of the amendment okay thank
you
there are several ways to do it this is
the way I've chosen to do it
you could also you could also have pass
it up you could also start with an ought
to pass and then ask for an amendment I
wrote the other way it's my choice
uh any other questions
all right
now just something to take the motion on
on
emotion is to approve up to pass
system to approve Amendment 05. 80 h
for Bond Bill house bill 235.
okay
do you need a second
uh yes
all right
any discussion
um
representative yes
yes representative fools
pardon
representative gold what's yes
representative
yes
Morgan votes yes representative Park yes
our votes yes representative Creighton
Creighton yes
great votes yes representative Dodge
yes
Dutch boots yes
representative Healy
votes yes representative Mayville
a representative Mayfield yes
Gable votes yes representative post
representative post votes yes those
votes yes representative Smith
representative Smith yes
Smith votes yes representative Spang
representative Spang votes yes
representative grassy representative
grassy votes yes yes representative
represent a representative gottling
votes yes
representative Cohen
yes representative Connors
oh it's yes that's yes representative
Bale
representative Vale votes yes Bill votes
yes representative Kelly representative
Kelly votes yes Kelly votes yes
representative Moran
representative Moran votes yes
representative
representative Deputy votes yes
he votes yes and chairman Zulu yes
21 yeses
okay on the
on the main motion about to pass EDS
amended
[Music]
any any discussion
seeing none please call the roll yes
representative
yes
let's give those yes representative
Gould yes
gold votes yes representative Morgan yes
Bergen votes yes representative Farm
um
representative Park votes yes
representative Creighton Creighton yes
Creighton votes yes representative Dodge
Dodge is yes
just yes representative post
representative post votes yes
representative Smith yes
yes
represents Spang
LED yes Bank votes yes representative
grassy
representative grassy votes yes that's
yes representative kotlin
representative gottling votes yes
representative Cohen representative
Cohen votes yes
representative Connors representative
Connors votes yes
yes representative Vale
representative Vale votes yes
it's an Avail votes yes representative
Kelly
representative Kelly votes yes yes
representative Moran
representative Moran votes yes
Rand votes yes and representative dutzie
representative detsee both yes
and Dusty votes yes chairman Susan uh
yes yes 21 days
yes and I will write the blur
Mr chair I missed who made the motion
and seconded it
uh need the motion
there's a representative Creighton
seconding yes ma'am thank you
all right on to the next one
house bill
relevant to standards for her and
probably plural substances in drinking
water and ambient groundwater again this
is a
a retread from previous year again same
issue
passage by the committee and that's from
cobit
in the uh the Senate uh so we have there
is a minor amendment that was posted for
the bills uh
representatives of Terror recognized
representative Smith
for a motion
thank you Mr chair I move ought to pass
as amended on House Bill 271 and the
amendment number is zero five seven
seven eight
seconds
okay
seconded by representative Spang uh do
you wish to uh do you wish to speak on
the amendment uh representative Smith
yes thank you Mr chair
um the amendment uh put together by
representative ranzullo adds the words
peer reviewed when in the discussion of
um how new pfas could get added to the
list of pfas of concern was through at
least one study and so this just added
the words peer-reviewed one
peer-reviewed study
it's still conducted in accordance with
generally accepted scientific principles
that demonstrates the pfas of concern is
known to cause or may reasonably blah
blah blah and you can read it but
um so it just adds those two words and
just clarifies things for people
thank you any discussion on the
amendment
if not
please call us
representative
that's representative yes
representative Doles yes
representative Morgan yes
working votes yes representative Barb
yes
our votes yes representative Creighton
Creighton yes great votes yes
representative Dodge yes
votes yes the clerk votes yes
representative feely roach yes yes
representative Mayville chess
yes
but yes representative Smith
representative Smith votes yes
representative Spang
are you saying it's Bank votes yes
thank both yes representative brassi
representative grassy votes yes grassy
votes yes representative gottling
representative gottling votes yes
representative Cohen representative
Cohen votes yes
representative Connors representative
Connors votes yes all right so it's yes
representative Bale
representative Veil boots yes Bill votes
yes representative Kelly
votes yes
Ellie votes yes representative Moran
representative debtsy
representative debtsy votes yes
he votes yes chairman Zula
chair votes yes
[Music]
but that was the question wasn't it we
already put it on the amendment I
thought
we did no this that was on the event
okay
all right on the octopus the motion for
UT to pass as amended any discussion any
further
there being none
the clerk please call the roll yes
yes
let's give those yes representative gold
both votes yes representative organ yes
yes
[Music]
representative Creighton Creighton yes
great that's yes president of Dodge
Dodge yes Dodge yes or the clerk votes
yes representative peely yes yes
representative Mayville
yes
representative post
representative post quotes yes
nurse votes yes representative Smith
representative Smith yes
Smith votes yes representative Spang yes
representative Grassi
grassy votes yes grassy events yes
representative gottling representative
gottling votes yes
this yes representative Cohen
representative Cohen votes yes
representative Connors representative
Connors votes yes
representative Vale
representative Vale Roots yes
yes representative Kelly representative
Kelly votes yes
representative Moran
Brett Moran votes yes
yes representative dutzy representative
debtsy votes yes
does he votes yes and chairman Zulu
votes yes
21-0 uh
is that
yes yep said no issue uh representative
Smith uh Blair I will do the committee
report
yep
yeah but who's gonna do the blurb
s
are you nice to me
all right on to the next one
all right uh next on to the next one
trying to go on it going into some kind
of alphabetical order or numerical order
house bill 158.
Brian Wetlands chair recognizes
representative
yes
a second second by representative
uh this this bill in in one form another
or another has been in front of this
house and is actually uh been in front
of the whole body
the language is very similar this this
actually has been this particular
subject matter was vetoed by our
governor and I think this just seems in
my eyes just another swing at the back
and I just think that there's a lot of
times
I'm sorry I just can't support this one
again
we'll still
yeah
on your second I yield
there any uh any any more discussion
the other representative
bill is this Mr chairman
pardon
some Villages all right representative
Smith and then who else
okay all right representative Smith
followed by representative Spang is
there
can I hear a other Mr chairman he wanted
to know what bill was Oh What Bill 158
representative Schmitz to speak
uh
don't hear you
been here
representative Smith there I go I'm here
I am thank you Mr chair and I rise in
opposition to the itl motion and there
is a reason yes this bill has been on
before us a few times but the reason is
is because the value of wetlands
is important for filtration of toxins
for keeping silt out of our lakes and
rivers and for numerous other uh reasons
habitat for wildlife and I just don't
want to see this bill go down without a
fight and I will leave the rest to the
prime sponsor and to representative
Spang thank you
representative Spain representative
thank you
here is whether or not uh we are going
to uh take a realistic
ecologically sound view of what a
wetland is I think that the way the
Wetland regulations are now it assumes
that a wetland is like a donut hole
where it is just round with no creaks
coming into it with no little Coast we
all know that there is no water body
except our swimming pool that looks like
that
and those
so I don't want to use the word fingers
and toes I think that that is
distracting
but these little coves and these little
indentations along the the shoreline of
a of a wetland are
I think obviously
a viable part of the Wetland and the way
the Wetland functions uh anything that
is living in that Wetland probably is
nesting whether it's a a bird or a fish
in those little shallows uh in the the
additions
to these to this wetland
the only way that one could possibly say
that this is not ecologically and
hydrologically connected to the whole
Wetland is if one were
worried about extending the amount of
the Wetland
um and I hadn't yet to see a reasonable
argument for that it certainly was not a
reasonable argument that was presented
to us with that absurd map that clearly
did not recognize what was before us
um I think that we ought to give the
governor a chance to redeem himself in
this this issue and to do what is
scientifically ecologically rational in
this instance uh this
thank you very much Mr chairman and
representative brasenson
yes thank you
yes Mr chairman thank you
um
it's I read the governor's view this
bill is passed by this committee twice
before and it had bipartisan support
both times it passed it passed the house
twice it ended up well this last time it
ended up on the floor or in the Senate
basically on the floor because of covet
but I read the governor's veto message
of this the first time around and most
of the opposition to this bill in fact
um they're opposed to the current law
it's not anything in this bill but
changes the current law that they're not
that they're opposed to things that are
in the current rsas
if somebody wants to change what they're
opposed to they need to submit another
bill
what this bill does is it allows a few
small communities in the state
to map out their Prime Wetlands
accurately and adopt Prime Wetlands
regulations every
community that currently has Prime
weapons designated
fits the criteria that's built nothing
more
but this bill does do though is
something that I think is very important
which the governor and others have just
ignored entirely is it gives an
exemption to D.O.T I mean that's going
to be advantage to State and communities
if DOD can go into work particularly
when you're looking at crisis situations
when we've had significant flooding in
the state UK needs to get in there and
they need to work quickly under current
under the current law they're held up
they've got to go through this process
they can't move as quickly as they could
this bill frees them from that
restriction and allows them to move
forward all it does is it allows a few
communities to accurately map their
weapons
it actually has a provision here with
government was concerned about because
more representation to local landowners
and it gives an exemption for DOT which
we do not currently have in the
ordinance in the rsas
everybody who's spoken including the
governor's veto has only been what's in
the current laws has nothing to do with
this bill and it's baffles me why he he
basically says that he's opposed to this
bill because of what's in current law
because this doesn't do anything in fact
makes it more his benefit
anyone else wish to speak on this bill
representative
representative Mayville to speak on the
speak on the bill to begin the motion
um representative Grassi I so appreciate
your passion in this topic and I agree
that there are really specific
designations for each prime wetlands and
that we must protect our New Hampshire
resources my chief concern with the
wording on this bill purely relates to
the appearance of considering the
potential effect on landowners instead
of protecting them
um I am not for this type of you know
potential land grabs I see the change in
your in the um you know the width of
these narrow areas from 50 to 100 and
that's what we heard over and over from
folks that were coming out and talking
about it was that they were really
concerned about what was going to happen
to the landowners and I think that as
um you know our constituents and as
legislators we have to think about the
people here as well as protect our
resources I'm with you with the resource
protection but I I I don't agree that we
can go in there and grab people's land
away from them
that's all
so yeah
yeah I'm sorry uh yes I I certainly
understand the concern that they have
and the thing is is that a lot of people
are concerned about that because on a
previous law a previous law which was
repealed it was actually a hundred foot
buffer and when people are talking about
taking the land they were talking about
that 100 foot muscle 100 foot buffer
doesn't exist and we're not putting that
in this bill so that's not something you
really need to be concerned about all
this does it's not taking anybody's
buildable land away from them all it
does is it means that the work they can
do within the web
you know what is considered Wetlands
what's within the world if they wanted
to under the way it is right now if they
wanted to fill in some Wetlands they
sort of put up they could because if
because they're not considered Prime
weapons
and they could still do it even if they
were considered primewells they just
have to go through a few more things to
make sure that they're not impacting the
habitat and the flood storage I mean
there are the 12 criteria that you've
got to take a look at as long as they're
not going to destroy
and and Wetland has to meet for it as
long as they're not going to destroy
those those Prime criteria
they can still develop even within the
Wetland but this doesn't take anybody's
land buildable land away from them it
takes that land which is which shouldn't
be protected which is for flood storage
and for water quality and for habitat
and sort of takes that out it's the
Wetland area they're all that we're
taking out we're not touching
developable land there are no more
buffers and this was something that in
past debates that we've had in input
that came from from the number of people
they said well you you meaning I can't
build on all this dry up on crutching
the dry up whatsoever it's just the
women that we're dealing with
this is my turn
uh I like the chair would like to
redress a few things that are being said
the old grandfathered Wetlands had 100
foot setbacks yes now when that when the
change occurred
it reverted to the set it the allowed
the setbacks to be set by the localities
I guarantee
that if a locality has is is going to be
making a prime wetland it the setback
will be
well at least a hundred feet if not more
what I mean
to say that there is no will be no
setback is in is is is like plainly
wrong
also we're talking about prime Wetlands
here not talking about about Wetlands
the wetlands that we are talking about
will still remain Wetlands they just
will not become part of the Prime weapon
and the issue around Prime Wetlands is
there is a there is state
enforcement around Prime Wetlands that
is different from Prime Wells I'll read
you something from that Jason stock
wrote from the six of them his sixth
legislative policy update to his
organization in New Hampshire Timber
Owners Association where he says
portions of a wetland less than 50 feet
wide could be eligible for designation
I.E inlets and Outlets or depressions
adjacent to a bog or swamp once
designated the regulatory permitting
requirements for any activity including
Forest management becomes a lot more
complex and costly I.E but a butter
notification Conservation Commission
review Wetlands assessments Etc
because this law remains a problem for
landowners seeking to conduct Forest
manager projects on properties with
prime Wetlands the nhtoa opposes it
currently there are two 32 New Hampshire
towns of prime Latins neetlands in in
and in some communities if the wet if
the inlets and Outlets were to become
designated large Parcels of land would
be landlocked behind the regulation that
is Jason's stock
uh
uh as far as the
the bill itself it talks about uh being
a making a wetland less making a portion
wet of a wet a prime Wetland that is
less than 50 feet at its narrowest point
how far the less than 50 feet 20 feet 10
feet 5 feet
is that still going to be a prime
Wetland and how long is this Prime
Wetland does it does it does it connect
a one acre Prime Wetland with another
acre Prime Wetland uh 100 uh
100 yards away that's those are the
questions everything is subjective
whereas the the rules on Prime Wetlands
now are very very specific
beyond that
I've said my piece there's actually no
further uh representative Spain
representative Spang four uh for comment
or question thank you
um I would like to point out that uh
there are considerable uh restrictions
on the landowner's use of their land
even if it is just a regular wetland
I would also that so they're not by
making it Prime you're not really
intruding that much on the use of their
land and I think uh representative
grassy has pointed out so you have to do
in a better
notification but it's not in a you're
not taking away developable land because
it's a it's Wetland like any other
wetland
in terms of the um
the setbacks this was a major move that
was made to take away the statutory
setbacks uh and it was left open up to
the municipality because it was decided
that the state shouldn't decide this
that it should be up to local control
where local people including the
landowners can uh say whether or not
they wish to do this now I've written
any number of wetland ordinances for
communities and I'll tell you that
um the the setbacks that they write for
Wetlands is all over the place some of
them are 25 feet some of them are 10
feet some of them are a rare one might
be 200 feet I've done a survey
um so it's entirely it's all over the
place in terms of what the municipality
decides they want for a a wetland
setback from a regular setback
or for say a shoreline setback so though
this does not really change anything
regarding the setbacks
um also and I think this is the most
important point
these these as they would additions
fingers and toes as that they've become
known
still have to have to satisfy the four
criteria for a regular Wetland you can't
just have a ditch and call it part of a
prime Wetland it still has to meet the
four criteria and in particular wildlife
habitat Etc so it can't just be anything
it has to be something that is in itself
a prime wetland
um and that is I think I'm hoping that
this is enough for people to consider uh
when they're talking about going back to
the original
Prime Wetland statute as it had been for
years and years until this this very
last change that made it
um I think uh something that is
ecologically
um hard to defend
foreign
all right
I recognize myself
let's talk a little bit about the four
functions of wetlands and this one has
to be for conscious okay
the 12 primary functions are
one of which one is wetland dependent
wildlife habitat
do mosquitoes count
educational potential
what kind of educational potential is
in that is what a wetland function I
mean I had an education in a wetland
once I've got I actually got lost in the
swap when I out Hunted
it it taught me a lesson I guess there
is another educational potential
noteworthiness
Shoreline anchoring nutrient sediment
trapping all of these things are Wetland
functions
many of these are just simply
uh simply subjective
I think most
people's backyards could meet these
Wetlands functions at least four of them
so it
this this are
these Wetlands functions
they're very subjective
so
I think we have
to make do we have we have and
Primal in the prime Wetlands wardenants
as it exists now
things that are not subjective
so let's simply
stick to what we have
and be done
any other questions any other comments
right
no questions no questions
saying no questions no and no comments
we're on the emotion of
itl
but please call the roll
chair representative gunski
representative gunski yes Penske votes
yes representative ghouls representative
gold yes
old votes yes representative Morgan yes
Oregon votes yes representative harp yes
our votes yes representative Creighton
Creighton yes great votes yes
representative Dodge yes
Dodge votes yes to clerk votes yes
representative Healy votes yes Billy
votes yes represent Mayville
representative Mayfield votes yes Naval
votes yes representative post
representative post quotes yes
post votes yes representative Smith
no
minutes votes no representative Spang
Spang no
Spang votes no representative brassy
grassy votes no
representative gottling representative
gottling votes no
representative gottling votes no
representative Cohen so Cohen votes no
one votes no representative Connors
representative Connor's votes no
200 votes no representative Vale
representative Dale votes now
bail votes no representative Kelly
no Kelly votes no Kelly votes no
representative Moran
Moran votes no
uh Moran votes no representative debsey
representative detsee votes no
representative votes no and chairman
uh yes yes
two
and relations ocean consensus
what
okay I guess we have it I got hurt yes
yeah yeah and you're right Mr chairman
good try
good try all right I will I'll write the
majority report who will write the money
before
we'll get it to you I'll probably end up
doing it all right I'll I'll I'll put
you down as a question mark
yes may I have the score again
the score is 11 to 10. 11 yes
then no
uh for Ikea
thank you you need it by the weekend
uh
that there you can be Sunday Monday
get to me Sunday night so I have a
chance to go through it yeah not a
problem thank you all right thank you
all right
moving right along
uh
house assistant 426. how's Phil
been to do House Bill 426
um
septic Shoreland septic system
United representative foreign
I'd like to recommend uh that we retain
HB 426
didn't want to hear a second second
by
Dodge
uh would you like to speak to yourself
Yes actually it would uh
we heard a lot of testimony on this and
adding this fourth section
I didn't feel based on what we had heard
from the testimonies
and there were some
I thought some complications as it was
written with a licensed septic designer
or you know versus a nicer licensed
septic evaluator so there was some
confusion in that part of the language
uh the change the 254 reference versus
the 200 is also a consideration that I'd
like to look into further because how is
that going to impact
individuals and the other one that
really
concerned me is when we heard from the
from the Realtors
one individual in particular had said in
his 50 years he has never sold the home
without a without a septic inspection
and the general consensus was upwards of
98 plus called houses sold
uh we're sold with septic inspections
part of the purchase and sales agreement
so I I question exactly
how many homes
on Lake on shorefront are actually being
sold without a without a thorough septic
inspection and I don't have that
particular information I would love to
know that and that may take some time
from the Realtors to see how much
property was actually moved in a period
of time and and exactly what we're
talking about because
what I'm seeing
with this bill is not a lot of substance
and change so I'd like to investigate it
further and that's why I would like to
retain it represent Spencer uh
was I recognized
[Music]
oh yeah oh God uh representative Dodge
would you like to speak to your second
um I really don't have much to say that
uh uh representative gunski has not um
he really covered a lot of uh a lot of
land there okay all right I'll then I'll
recognize representative spank
okay thank you very much and um
I think that representative gunski has
done the right thing here
um there there was there were some
complications that were introduced by
Des at the hearing that kind of came out
of the blue uh because they had not been
brought up uh when it was the bill was
farther down in the ranks with the staff
um and I think that the questions that
Des raised are are worth investigating I
do think that uh this bill uh came out
of a two-year commission to study the
problems of water pollution by
underperforming septic systems it was a
a widely representative uh group with a
lot of experts in it including people
who are Wetland
um evaluators I'm sorry septic
evaluators and septic uh system uh and
designers
and they actually requested one of the
changes that Des wanted
now
the letter that was sent out by the
Realtors
and I'm getting many many many copies of
the exact same thing
um
was kind of misleading in a way and
um they were the commission as a whole
voted to unanimously to support the
findings of the commission except for
the Realtors and the commission argued
with the realtors that their uh their
problems were not actually uh in fact
based on what's happening in uh on the
ground
when they say that the houses are all
the properties are already inspected
that is not the septic system what we're
talking about here is having the septic
system its stealth looked at to see if
it is underperforming what they're
talking about is the required site
assessment which just says whether
there's enough land there to support a
septic system and whether the soils are
correct for it but it even the people on
the commission who were uh site septic
evaluators complained that there were
septic systems being sold to people who
did not know that the septic systems
were underperforming
so this is the way that
um Des was talking about changing the
bill uh it would have just sent this
report to the home Bill the the
potential home buyer which I think is
pro any information a home buyer can get
is probably uh for the better and they
should certainly be willing to pay the
um the marginal increase in cost to find
out
um but I think that it's also very
important that the report be sent to Des
and to the local code enforcement
officer so that if there is say somebody
had a summer Cottage that now they're
living in full time with their whole
family and the amount of uh dishwashing
and laundry et cetera et cetera et
cetera is now much more than it used to
be the code enforcement officer could
keep an eye on it
um
the the issue that we're talking about
here is that our surface waters are
being polluted by underperforming septic
systems and this has been proven by the
uh
volunteer groups who have worked with
landowners to try to do something about
it and they've cleaned up their legs
they've gotten rid of the cyanobacteria
this is what the bill was attempting to
do
the fact that the Des
Amendment creates real questions I think
is good because it's good for us to be
looking at this to resolve those and
also the commission was frustrated
because they were because of covet and
the interruption in our work we weren't
able to get around to actually
implementing any of the recommendations
that the commission had come up with
including possibly either regulatory or
working with volunteers or working to
fund uh improvements in water quality so
I appreciate representative gunski's
putting forward this motion to uh
to retain the bill I think it will be
move us forward in terms of addressing
this problem
any other
questions or comments on the motion
saying none
on the motion absolutely
to regain Insurance H House Bill 426 so
we'll click please call the world
representative gunski representative uh
gunsky book yes
yes representative Gould yes
yes
working votes yes representative carb
yes representative Creighton Creighton
yes yes representative Dodge yes Dodge
votes yes the clerk votes yes
representative feely Keely
votes yes representative Mayville
representative Mayville votes yes
people votes yes representative post
representative post votes yes
representative yes representative Smith
representative Smith yes
representative Smith votes yes
representative Spang Bang Yes yes
representative brassy representative
grassy votes yes
representative gottling representative
gottling votes yes
representative Cohen
yes
no one votes yes representative Connors
representative Connor's votes yes honors
what's yes representative Vale
yes representative Kelly Kelly votes yes
Kelly votes yes representative Moran
uh Moran wrote yes
yes representative dutzie representative
dutzie votes yes
yes
should remind folks I think the uh the
rule is that in the bowling we are in
the voting mode you should have your the
you should be appearing live that a not
a high school picture
yes
uh you sure so I I was I was got an
email of a
text message to that effect
and that is the rules uh going uh
I'll spill 269 abandoned cables
uh chair recognizes
uh
representative Smith
or a
uh
promotion
uh thank you Mr chair and I make a
motion of itl
motion of itl by representative Smith is
there a second I'll second the motion
second second
by uh was that
representative was that representative
Bale or absolutely I can't see the
everybody's this big
it's representative honors
representative Connors thank you very
much
uh would you like to speak to your
motion representative Smith yes thank
you the thing I wrote down in my no
I heard this bill was need to complete
rewrite
um there are so many unanswered
questions about uh how big a problem it
is whether it's bad or good for the
environment to take the cables up uh how
deep are they in what does abandoned
mean it just seems like there's a lot of
work that needs to be done on the issue
if the indeed it is an important issue
for the
the legislature to deal with but it's
not our job to totally uh rewrite bills
completely and I think this one should
be brought back by somebody next year
with more complete information and so
that's why I make a motion to itl it
representative Carlos would you like to
speak to your uh
your second I have nothing to add thank
you
yep
uh representative for statement comment
thank you speaker thank you Mr chair I
have to agree 100 with representative
Smith when I first looked at the title
of this bill I thought wow underwater
bandic cables I mean I can't imagine
those things just
it you know Gathering up underneath the
water and what's it doing to the water
quality but once we started to dig into
the build and there's fine schedules and
who's responsible I mean can we can we
ask a police officer in a community to
identify the cable that kind of stuff it
just didn't make sense at all there's
just a lot of a ton of work that needs
to be done to the building I agree 100
uh the only the only real path to this
bill is itm
what else which is no hands raised No
Hands no no hands go ahead and raise at
the table seeing none I will ask the
clerk on emotional itl on 269.
uh please call the roll
okay representative gunski guns Eagles
yes
yes representative pools yes
old votes yes representative
yes
organ boots yes representative Farm yes
firefoods yes representative Creighton
Creighton yes Creighton votes yes
representative Dodge Dodge yes
representative yes yes representative
post representative post votes yes
yes
representative Smith
representative Smith yes
Smith votes yes representative Spang
hey votes yes
representative Grassi
representative grassy votes yes
representative kotlin representative
gottling votes yes
vote to US Representative Cohen yes
representative Connors
representative Connors votes yes
representative
representative Vale votes yes
Bill votes yes representative Kelly
Kelly votes yes
representative Moran
Moran votes yes Korean votes yes
representative dutzie representative
Dempsey votes
yes
both being 21 to nothing
obviously I'm consent
uh
representative Smith you are writing the
blur or somebody of your designee uh
we're negotiating over here
um but yes we will get you we will
Community report in the next uh
by the end of the weekend yep that's
that sounds fine
I'll put your name down and I'll just
Smith yeah at l
um
you know
okay chairman
um on 426 I didn't have a 10 cent
calendar for the 26th okay
okay uh next bill house bill 447.
recognizes
uh
representatives of Smith
I will defer to representative Kelly on
this
okay representative Kelly for remote
this is 447 correct
447 yes
I motion uh we we vote inexpedient to
legislate
motion is an expedient to legislate
uh is there second through the motion
I'll second it rep Smith
representative Smith seconds
representative Kelly we wish to speak to
your motion
I think that the idea of protecting you
know scuba divers is a good one I'm not
a scuba diver myself but I think that
it's a good idea but I think that the
those devices and what they can
currently do or what they do
um just doesn't fit with the with
mandating them to be used in Aid
um in a rental setting
representative Smith do you wish to
speak to your second
although yes I would thank you Mr chair
um although I feel really badly for
anyone who is injured or disappears on a
scuba diving trip
um I believe the technology uh which
would be needed to prevent something
like this from happening would be
exorbitant for a dive shop to keep the
units on hand because if you really
wanted one that was going to get you at
depth and at the surface
and let people know where you were
you're talking about in the thousands
because the inexpensive ones either only
work on the top or only work once or
twice and I just think it's not
practical
um and the
when someone is on the surface they can
easily purchase or get a free safety
sausage which puts up about eight feet
in the air so someone can find you if
you're out on the water and also I think
with New Hampshire's very uh small
amount of miles of Coastline
this is more a problem that happens when
large dive boats with 20 30 40 divers go
out and they easily lose somebody on the
way so um I think that although the
intention is a good one I think this is
not a good Bill thank you
anyone wish to speak on the motion
I'm sure you have uh representative harp
representative Iris recognized thank you
Mr chairman I appreciate the comments of
the maker of the motion and the second
uh just for the record as you may recall
this is a constituents bill so uh I will
be voting against it to support my
constituent thank you perfectly
understandable
uh anyone else to speak under the motion
sir representative Mabel representative
Mayville to speak on the motion
um just quickly I
you know totally understand the reason
behind the bill and you know support
those reasons about safety but I am um I
am going to vote for the itl simply
because I don't believe that we should
be mandating business practices such as
mandating equipment at a sporting goods
store would provide to their customers
and so for me it's really just totally
about supporting business
anyone else to speak on the bill sure
you have representative post
representative post to speak on the bill
yes thank you Mr chairman
um my um recommendation of itl is due to
the liability that these businesses
would face if they weren't able to
provide or if something went wrong so
again like Mary representative Mayville
um
I I think it was not a good bill for for
the industry
anyone else speak on the bill
seeing none
look on House Bill 447 motion of IPL the
clerk please call the roller yes thank
you chair representative gumsky gunski
votes yes
votes yes representative Gould yes
votes yes representative Oregon yes
working votes yes representative Park no
representative Park votes no
representative Creighton Creighton yes
great votes yes representative Dodge
of OTs
votes yes the clerk votes yes
representative healing yes yes
representative represent Senator
Mayville books yes Naval votes yes
representative post yes representative
post votes yes
that's good yes representative
representative Smith yes
Smith votes yes representative Spang
it's an explain votes yes
representative brassy representative
grassy votes yes yes representative
kotlin representative gottling votes yes
I think both yes representative Cohen
Senator Cohen votes yes no one votes yes
representative Connors representative
Connor Switz yes
representative Vale
votes yes representative Kelly
votes yes yes representative Moran
yes
votes yes representative dutzie
representative datsy votes yes
and chair
yes yes 22.
representative Kelly uh you will be
providing the blur for uh yes yep I'll
write that one too
see you again so you'll become a
superstar
this is a one-time thing after this
uh
is this on
consent representative of our
I have no problem with consent Mr Kim
pardon
says I'm okay okay
thank you thank you very much all right
the next one the next bill is
house bill 534.
relative to Municipal control of certain
Frozen water bottles do you recognizes
representative
Mr chair I recommend the itl HB 530 you
said 534. yeah itl on HB 534
uh it's very second and second that bill
check in and use that
representative
uh would you like to speak to your well
just quickly I don't have too too much
obviously
I think you heard from Fish and Game and
your testimonies very convincing
obviously they opposed this bill uh if
it's any body of water under 10 acres or
more quarters and those Waters by the
state of State for the public who would
have jurisdiction over these uh you know
who would have the resources and the
seasonal resources to enforce or reform
rescue operations I mean it just really
this uh
as much as I understand uh why this
legislation was put forward I think he's
thinking it doesn't fit when the state
of New Hampshire so I'd recommend an
idea
I hope that I'm calling would you like
to speak to your second representative
gunsky's explanation is very
comprehensive I'm okay
thank you is there any
one else who wishes to speak to the
motion of IPL
so you know what uh this is just a chair
would like to observe observe
there's an observation
that this bill
was imposed by everybody and their
brother
Des Parks Fish and Game
uh Farm Bureau
the Snowmobile Association
the Timberland Owners Association
uh
even Captain Donald from the you know he
opposed it
so
you know
50 000 people can't be wrong so uh
I think you know I so I I agree with the
uh with the motion of IPL
and on that
seeing no one else wishing to speak
oh Cliff please call the role on House
Bill 534
thank you chair representative gunski
representative gunski votes uh yes
that's evos yes representative bills yes
votes yes representative Morgan yes
Oregon votes yes representative harp yes
our Foods yes representative Creighton
Creighton yes yes representative Dodge
Dodge votes yes Excellence yes clerk
votes yes representative Healy
votes yes representative
yes
representative post
representative post votes yes yes
representative Smith Smith yes
representative Spang representative
Spang votes yes yes representative
representative grassy votes yes grassy
votes yes representative
representative gottling votes yes
bottling votes yes representative Cohen
Senator Colin votes yes
representative Connors representative
Connors votes yes yes representative
Vale
representative Dale votes yes Bill votes
yes representative Kelly votes yes Kelly
votes yes representative Moran
BOS yes
Moran votes yes and uh representative
dutzie
representative Dusty votes yes
let's see books yes and chair
uh votes yes
[Music]
unless somebody else would like to like
to try their hand that one would you
like to try your hands
will be done
all right
moving right a lot
all right the next bill under
consideration is
I'll spill
571.
healing the prohibition against ohrp
travel on Hoyt road Marsh
that recognizes the representative
Mr chair I make a motion to retain HD
I want you to retain the house bill 571
is there a second seconded
represents representative Smith motion
second is
uh would you like to speak to your not
sure
you're running out of gas too yeah Steve
okay uh as much as I
am dissatisfied with the way this
this band went into place as a uh you
know a line item and the last items
budgeted in hb2
I think the committee should spend a
little bit more time familiarizing
themselves with the actual Marsh uh
what's going on where the residents are
located I think there's still a little
bit of work we can do on this bill make
sure that we do all the residents
justice so I think at this time it would
be in our best interest to maintain this
thank you
representative Smith would be like to
speak with your second sure thank you Mr
chair
one of the issues one of the biggest
issues we deal with in this committee is
balancing the rights of user groups on
public land and public Waters and this
is another example of that balancing the
needs of those who want peace and quiet
at their homes with the needs of those
who want to recreate on the public Pro
public Waters even if they're ice so I
think that you know in the previous bill
that we just itl'd was a blanket uh
change and this gives us this retaining
this bill gives us more time to research
and study and do a better job with the
situation of motorcycle riding on uh
Quake Road Marsh so I support the uh
retaining
is there any other
comments
on House Bill to representative
571 representative Cohen on the bill
I I too support uh the motion to retain
this bill the reason is uh last year I
had privilege of serving on this
committee and just due to covert
restrictions this time we didn't get a
lengthy um amount of testimony from some
on both sides of the issue and nobody
from any of the local governments that
have bordered the issue like Concord
came into con uh testified so I just
want to make sure the um full existing
board appears in depth some of the
things that we've got to hear this time
and I think we retain it will give us a
little more time to just really explore
the sides of this issue
or any other comments
or
questions on the the motion to retain
representative grasseson representative
grassy
yes Mr chairman thank you
um I think there's some there's other
things that are just as important I mean
we can listen to both sides and people
who want to recreate the area and the
people who want to stop the recreation
sometimes we don't get a lot of
testimony from the experts this is a
wildlife refuge that's out there and I
think we need to get some scientific
information on what the impact
could that's that's occurring on the
wildlife that's in that area and and how
we basically voiding the fact that it's
a protected area allowing these juices
out there we haven't had that kind of
data presented to the committee I think
we do need that kind of better better
and that's stuff that by retaining it
you can reach out and get that
information
is there any other
discussion on the bill on the on the
motion
see none
that's a little clerk please call a roll
on the motion to retain house bill 571.
thank you chair representative gunski
representative gumski is a yes
representative gunski yes representative
Gould yes
gold votes yes representative organ yes
Morgan votes yes representative harp yes
yes
votes yes the clerk votes yes
representative Healy roach yes really
votes yes representative
yes Naval votes yes representative post
representative post votes yes post votes
yes representative Smith Smith yes Smith
votes yes representative Spain bang
votes yes yes representative grassy
representative grassy vote Yes Yes
representative
representative gottling votes yes
governing votes yes representative Cohen
yes
representative Connors representative
Connors votes yes honors votes yes
representative Bale
President
Bill votes yes representative Kelly
Kelly boats yes Billy votes yes
representative Moran
post yes
representative
that's evos yes and chairs
yes 21. next
21 to nothing
[Music]
is there a question
well I I thought I heard some things
you'll be asking me a question I think
somebody had their mic on oh
all right okay
can we take a five minute recess
I think we can
restroom break
[Music]
five minute recess we'll probably will
go into 10.
foreign
okay until you're off you
okay
are we ready
you wear a mask I can wear a Nixon can't
not wear it so
all right good night
but the final hit of the day
while we're leaning back to order
discuss House Bill 611
doesn't mean it gets a
business still not an early Bill all
right
House Bill 611 abolishing fluoridation
in water
and asked
form of motion
thank you Mr chair Mr chair I make a
motion to retain hb611.
to raise second to the motion
I'll second representative harm
representative harp just a second
okay
do you like to speak to your mother yeah
I can speak to it just a little bit uh
this is a very challenging bill for us
and uh I know it's very
polarizing people are you've got this
camp in that camp and there's still
information coming in uh actually just
as of recently I think a day or so ago
one of our fine Representatives sent us
over some additional information and I
haven't even actually gone through that
information yet uh
uh I just think this deserves uh due
diligence to just go and listen to
everybody that wants to to bring their
uh
they're positioned forward
and with the setting that we've had this
year it's been a challenge with that and
like I said I know there's a lot of
people that have spoken on this but it's
been challenging to get to everything so
I just feel that it would be in our best
interest to uh we changed this bill and
take a really heavy swing at it
representative Hobb do you wish to speak
to your motion
thank you Mr chairman just briefly I
agree with the representative gunski
this seems to be a very polarized uh
topic and a bill
um from experts dentists to all and
reports and the public and the Public's
right to know so uh that's why
right representative representative
Spang knew is to speak to your promotion
but we you wish to speak
yes and anyway yeah the
they felt that
involves
this bill does not belong before our
committee this is not a water quality
issue this is not a resource issue this
is a Health and Human Services issue and
I would like to see uh it go over to the
committee that is best equipped to deal
with health and human uh human health
issues
that's it thank you
sir you have
representative Moran uh representative
Moran uh to speak to in the uh speak on
the motion
yes I would concur with my colleague
um which colleagues uh Spain
representative Spang uh this I
personally believe that this bill should
be an expedient to legislate I think
this bill should die
um we have um terrible Medicaid benefits
in the state for dental insurance and
passing a bill like this no matter what
committee it comes out of will downshift
cost to Independent Dental owners
throughout the state
I'm hopeful that over in the Senate that
they're working on increasing the dental
benefits but one thing that I hope this
bill has done in this committee if we do
get the expansion of Medicaid dental
services from the Senate when it comes
to the house that we can understand the
DraStic need
for adequate dental services in our
state uh the fluoride is certainly a
public health measure we're in the
middle of a public health pandemic I
can't see us taking a shot at Public
Health initiatives especially when we
have such poor
um Quality
Medicaid services for protecting the the
health of our teeth which is directly
affected in preventing heart disease and
other major health issues uh you know
certainly certainly
be a rising cost for for Health Care uh
in the state if we did allow this bill
to go forward and if it did pass
realize that
just second uh this uh this previous
speaker the this bill is to be retained
at least that's the motion it is not the
itl
oh yes I know I was just sharing my
opinion that I think it should be all
right
okay all right representative brassy
yes Mr chairman thank you a lot of you
members have received information that
I've sent to you a lot of information
sheets from even from different
countries uh at the shoe I feel very
strongly about and I would like to see
at itl but I will support the retaining
issue because I think it's important I
also do agree with representative Spang
I don't know why we have this in our
committee it should go to health and
services it shouldn't be in our
committee at all
um I guess this is the third time it
come here and it's unfortunate that it
does come to our community because it's
not a place where uh on an issue that we
really should be dealing with I would
hope that the chairman would uh would
certainly advise leadership that you
know really needs to be a different
committee other than ours but in the
meantime we'll retain it we'll uh we'll
find more information to you about this
and uh hopefully by the time we get to
the end of it eventually it will be
defeated
um in in the final final vote that we
take thank you John representative Kelly
yeah I don't want to be the guy who know
who's uh so thank you Mr chairman I
don't want to be the guy who's known for
keeping us past our scheduled time so I
don't want to go into my all my remarks
I do have a I've been doing quite a bit
of of leg work on this
um to figure out how it affects our
state um I think we heard a lot about
the national conversation
um there's a lot of Statistics uh about
our state specifically that I think need
to be shared at some point so I'll
support the motion to retain but I agree
with representative Moran that I would
much rather see this itl and move on but
I'll save those remarks for
for a future session
representative Cohen for walking really
quick
um I will support the retain I think
this is a drinking water issue that
needs to be explored in our committee uh
at this point
but I will support the motion to retain
and have that discussion in the summer
or whatever
anyone else uh
uh as chair I move uh I'll tell you my
feelings on this reason I'm supporting
one reason I'm supporting retention uh I
do support the bill and then uh and the
bill that I see in front of me is I
don't believe is ready for prime time uh
if you look at the bill uh it has one
more uh one sentence concerning uh
fluoride and water and it has a whole
page concerning
fluoride in school district water it the
just by the way this bill is put
together it focuses on the wrong thing
that should be fixed uh also my concern
is that we are in the first year here
uh you we concentrate heavily on budgets
and other issues and this is a very
uh it's a very very let's say polarizing
bill it's it goes it cuts across uh
party lines there are some people who
are foreign some people are against on
both sides so this will be a hard-fought
bill uh I don't want to see it tabled
which will probably very well could
happen in the first year and then we
would be if it were tabled in the first
year we would have it back the second
year and ironically with this uh I'm
going to have this bill get get a one
shot and that would should be in the
this in the SEC in the second year so
that's where I that's where I stand on
the bill uh I don't know if anybody else
has any any questions or comments no
other answer no no one else up on the
bill to on a motion to retain
I'll spill 611.
Cliff please call the roll yes thank you
chair representative gunski
representative gunski votes yes
Penske boats yes representative Gould
yes
yes representative Morgan yes
Oregon votes yes representative yes
our votes yes representative Creighton
yes yes representative Dodge
yes Dodge votes yes votes yes
representative Healey
votes yes representative
legal votes yes representative post
representative post books yes
yes representative Smith
yes
representative Spang representative
Spang votes no
representative snow representative
grassy representative grassy votes yes
representative gottling representative
gottling votes yes
representative uh Cohen instead of Cohen
votes yes
representative Cohen votes yes
representative Connors representative
Connor's votes yes
representative Vale
representative Vale votes yes
representative Bale votes yes
representative Kelly
representative Kelly votes yes
representative Moran
yes
representative
representative Dempsey votes yes
and
chairman yes that's yes that's 20.
I think we're done we got is there any
other any other business
good morning before we adjourn
it looks like we're finished
but I'll celebrate at once
finished our bills for until
[Music]
um
so as we end our business for the day I
just wanted to say how much I appreciate
each and every one of you I I've learned
a lot from your opinions and the work
that you've done and I I really do I
truly as a citizen of New Hampshire I
appreciate the work that you do and what
we've done in this committee I'm just
very proud of us
foreign
yes I I wanted to Echo the same
sentiment as representative Mayville
um I thought today went
um very well we had differing opinions
we worked it true again we learned so
much from each other and and the people
that called in
um changed my mind on a couple things
um that I was pretty steadfast on so I
really appreciate working with all of
you
um and I'd also like to know do we know
when the next session days are
[Music]
the next session day it's not yeah I it
hasn't been established yet
it's
it's going to be so but I have not heard
anything uh you know is that the
leadership was yet to be established and
Kelly sir yes representative Kelly
just to again to Echo but uh
representative post and representative
Mabel said I don't know if any of you
have had an opportunity to sit through
some of the other committees
um there's a lot more contention and a
lot less getting done so I just
appreciate all of you for for you know
being civil and sitting here and talking
and figuring stuff out you've been great
to work with
all right
and I you know I agree I mean I know
what's going on in other committees
and I think it's all news representative
Smith
she she seems to know what she seems to
know
a good way to go she's a good resource
oh gotta turn it around Minecraft
forget about what I said
thank you everybody thank you I want to
agree with representative having been uh
this you know been in this committee uh
under the leadership of Representative
Smith it is in his
it was that way last session and I you
know we want to continue that discussion
so it's been a wonderful committee to
work on and I truly appreciate it
we can we can disagree without being
disagreeable
[Music]
at least last year last year at least I
didn't have to deal with zoom and hybrid
meetings yeah
believe me it you you miss for the folks
who haven't served on the committee when
it's together
it's a much better experience than
uh the way it's going now I mean
and I that we still have seem to have
done the job so
thank you thank you very much thank you
Andy thank you everyone thank you Andy
thank you all yes thank you Andy thank
you everyone see you later all right